foreign
what up guys it is Tuesday and that
means it is a great area with myself
Sarah Garvey and the woman who owns your
internet algorithms right now yeah it is
just pretty things thank you Sarah what
up guys okay we have a great show for
you today we are talking about misogyny
versus missandry but
before we even get started all right if
you have watched
two or more of our videos uh-huh and you
have not subscribed tell them then we
have what Bell beef what have we got
beef exactly so you better get doing
that right now over to you pal okay guys
um thank you for tuning in tonight a
couple announcements before we start the
stream the first being make sure you
like the video on your way and the like
is the most important metric that
YouTube uses in order to push out these
streams so if you think the message is
important you think these are important
topics that people should watch make
sure you like the stream also all super
chats over ten dollars will be read
today
um
that
um we are saving for an 8K camera right
blessing
yeah he's he's nodding
um so all super chats are going towards
an 8K camera we need to raise about like
2 000 more dollars for it so
um on top of that we have two clips
channels so the first being just pearly
clips and the second being Pearl daily
make sure you go subscribe to both we
have two different editors on the
accounts it just gives you a little
different like types of clips for both
um on top of that we have four
membership tiers the first lets you be a
part of the chat today um that should be
linked in the description it's also of
the pinned comment on this live
um the second you get the Discord and
the behind the scenes Vlog we're getting
really heavy into Discord I've been
learning how to use it this month so
make sure you sign up for that
um the third is you get to connect with
me on social media and the fourth is a
one-on-one call with me once a month um
I actually give really good YouTube
advice um I've helped a lot of people
grow their channels so if you are
interested in learning like how to build
a YouTube channel and the best practices
for that I would really recommend the
one-on-one session with me once a month
um other people you know just have other
things they want to like ask me your
questions so it's a it's a cool you know
tier
um they just want to be close to you but
I just want to be close to you
that's what it is I don't know
please don't sign up for that reason
don't do that
um okay the next go follow my Instagram
it's just dot pearly things you have to
type out the whole thing because I am
Shadow banned on Instagram but we just
hit 50 000 followers so
um you know go follow that on top of
that
um I have two Tick Tock accounts right
now just probably things dot four and
just probably things dot five um they
took away one two and three but they
cannot get rid of me I can't get rid of
you bro they can't they try to you own
the algorithms right now and even even
if they do I'm like all over Tick Tock
number six will pop ups number seven
will pop up yeah they can they keep
taking some of y'all keep taking my
usernames though they know I'm about to
take that next one yeah I don't know
whoever's doing that stop it rude and
then posting your content on the channel
yeah so people think it's
yeah I see you guys
um also thank you guys last week we hit
400 000 subscribers and since that week
is that what we are now what are we at
430 000 subscribers we have 30 000 in a
week we are gonna hit 500k and knows I'm
crazy
um also guys Super Chat what you guys
want us to do for 500k um some people
have been suggesting a certain live
stream
um of what exactly
um well like a really long one well like
48 hours no I really I really I don't
want to do that so if you guys have
um a different you know suggestion for
what we should do at 500k let me know in
the comments also if you want to come on
the show DM Eddie his link is in the
description
um I think that's all the announcements
I have but we do have some guest here
it's not just aspel yeah I guess we
could do that well basically I guess we
could do that right yeah
um we're gonna go around and introduce
our guests guests can you tell us your
name your age your relationship status
and
a fun fact about you we'll start over
here
so we do what's going on uh my name is
Mark
age I'm 34 and what else do you want to
know fun fact fun fact I'll take
everything seriously
fair enough you don't joke around at all
no joke that's not a joke fair enough
okay I won't I won't make any jokes
[Laughter]
my name's Claire I'm 32 and I'm single
and fun facts I don't know I don't know
it was fun
um I've got two rabbits that's one
it's cute it's cool it is fun
okay uh my name is Alexander Alex
um I am 27.
Bachelor and
fun fact is
I don't know I go skiing once a year I
guess I don't know are you push boy nice
it's quite cheap
um hi my name is Tyler I'm 20 and I am
in a relationship
talk closer to your mic oh a fun fact
about me is I'm into Beauty okay
yes
nice okay well that's our guess uh we're
gonna get into it straight away guys and
girls however you choose your pronouns
whatever you call yourselves nowadays
um uh blessing we have a first video
what I'm gonna do is that we're going to
play this video we're going to get your
guys views on it
um like we said this messenger versus uh
sorry misogyny versus misandri and we'll
get you know you guys using it after you
see it
listen when you're ready
foreign
I used to walk in this place
where
um this Square it's next to the farm I
used to work at what area is it in it's
uh
next to Warren Street Station
okay
so Central Central
yeah yeah so we're gonna see we're gonna
see what happened there Warren Street
Station
see what you guys think
when blessed is ready
he's working Fast and Furious over here
guys so don't worry about it all right
he's working Fast and Furious blessing
is good we're good
um as a matter of fact before blessing
gets done let's just say
um does anybody know what missandry is
yeah
well the actual definition that I have
here of Miss entry is
I'll tell you what Miss Andre is
missandry is a dislike of contempt for
or ingrained prejudice against men
ingrained ingrained dislike of contempt
for or ingrained prejudice against men
but ingrained is a very interesting yeah
that's like kind of built in there yeah
built in you well it's kind of I think
it's kind of built in society yeah yeah
I was gonna say that I think it's built
into feminism like the whole the idea of
the patriarchy is innately misunderstood
you ever think about like there's
certain terms we use in society that are
very much like take accountability away
from the woman like we say knocked up
even though it takes two to tango but it
sounds like he knocked her up yeah but
on the flip side of that you read
headlines where it's I think we've got
we can hear okay are we good we're gonna
continue guys and we're gonna watch the
video I'm gonna get you guys is um
views and opinions on this
stuff
where were you I'm not talking today
[Music]
someone okay if I don't someone else
will okay okay it's perfectly fine yeah
okay thank you you're definitely right
yeah yeah
foreign
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's nothing don't give me that [ __ ]
okay
pathetic you're so [ __ ] pathetic
intense
my blood is hot
um right as you saw uh there were two
scenarios there uh one with a man-monger
woman
what was the difference
and why was there a difference do you
think
with the way the public reacted
I think it's um
it's actually quite sad
um the difference is no one came to the
man's Aid
um there was a part where a lady had
well majority of the women
in that scene when laughing also
alongside with the men as well I kind of
think it's um
it's quite shameful to see that it's not
taken seriously although she was doing
exactly the same thing in the reverse
roles no one came to his Aid no one
thought it was anything serious
it was um
yeah I guess it's a pure example of what
goes on in every day
do you think it's it's okay to hit dude
people generally think that Society
thinks it's okay for men to suffer from
physical abuse from women yeah
I believe so I feel like people feel
like
talking tonight sorry I feel like people
feel like
it's not as deep as if a woman
was to hit a man you know me no
I think you're gonna have to run that
run that part again what do you mean
like what do I mean yeah yeah do you
think Society thinks it's okay for
men to go through physical abuse because
um we saw there it was justified I think
I think the way it's seen is um if a
woman does it it's not seen as heavier
yeah and it's poor across like that
because you know they are deemed as you
know the Pharisees and they always ask
what did he do yeah yeah right there's
no questions asked on the other way
around yeah you deserve better than that
you know yeah like if a girl's going
crazy it's always like what did he do
what do girls always say what did he do
to make her yeah but no you're just
crazy I don't and one of the lines from
there I think was quite interesting is
that the guy came and said oh yeah you
deserve better than that you don't have
to take that but no one said that to the
man
do you know what I mean so it's like
what does a man have to take it I think
it's what's put out there a man has to
take it I think it's seen as now if a
woman does anything of that nature we
are
automatically by default expected to
accept that
because at the end of the day we don't
you know there's gonna be
tons of other people with the similar
kind of traits and it's not going to get
any better so we have to kind of be
content with the kind of treatment we're
receiving and this hope for it to
improve you understand and that just
depends on the kind of guy you are
um moral coding and I guess it's what
was pushed out there for the man to be
weakened right to accept it
to um I don't think it's weakened yeah I
think it's I think I think it is to for
a man to be weakened because at the end
of the day I don't think anybody should
be hitting anybody I think violence is
violence
I've had this conversation with a few
people
you know say oh we are the girls we
cause she's not as built as you a man is
built with muscle then I say okay let's
put a gun into the equation I know
that's a bit extreme but if someone
picks up a trigger you know a female
picks up a gun a guy picks up the gun
they both pull the trigger does the same
thing right yeah so if you go up to
Dwayne The Rock Johnson and you punch
him No One's Gonna Be Mad Or No One's
Gonna feel bad for you when you get
punched back
right yeah I don't think I'll be
punching him but yeah but that's what
I'm saying like girls like if the
argument is that the girls are weaker
like then you could say the thing if a
weaker man goes up to a stronger man and
hits him do we feel bad when he gets hit
back no but it's kind of weird because I
guess you'll be seen as bullying then in
the hospital what do you mean
pickle someone your own size if you're
saying a wee come on you know what I'm
saying if the weaker man picks a fight
with the bigger man um and then the
bigger man hits back nobody feels bad
for the weaker man because he picked the
fight but for some reason with women
it's not the same like if a woman picks
a fight with a man and it's hitting a
man but if she gets hit back people
that we saw if the man was to retaliate
if the man was to retaliate during that
time right it's a different board game
yeah but the chances are he's if I was
to punch you he punched me back you're
gonna hurt me a lot more I'm not
justifying here but but that is truth
you know you are the strongest sex so
I'm not saying that I should I'm not
gonna I don't go around punching men and
I wouldn't but because as a woman I know
that if I did and he hit me they're
trying to say is going to hurt me like
the domestic
but violence like statistics oh I'm with
you and I'm not with you
um you have a point but indeed you you
spoke on a narrative of your weaker
because you're a woman yeah yeah but
that is that is biological is it not uh
we could take the same example with
Dwayne The Rock Johnson like it's by
like he's huge biologically and so if a
skinny man picks a fight with a big man
and he punches back nobody feels bad for
the skinny guy of course but but
domestic violence over here a woman's
dying every three to four days that's
everywhere all right yeah no of course
but I'm talking about the UK so I don't
know what the opposing argument so well
most um domestic violence is unmutual so
both parties are hitting each other but
one-sided abuse is actually more common
for um men to be hit one-sided than
woman to be hit one-sided
I've actually got some statistics for
domestic violence when it comes to women
and men
um against men specifically because I'm
I've gone to the National Center of
domestic violence right and it actually
says this male victims to find a finding
was mirrored in an annual crime survey
for England and Wales which found a
quarter of all domestic abuse crimes in
2018 to 2019 were committed against a
male victim
in the same year 16 men died at the
hands of their partner or ex-partner
compared with 80 women the crime survey
stats also showed that 3.8 of men which
is equal to 786
000 were victims of domestic abuse in
2018-2019 so I'll be very interested in
that that video except having a woman
that was bigger than the man right do
you think I was done Typecast like do
you think that was done deliberately
just to probably no I think they just
they just got who they could to play the
roles but it'll be interesting if you
had a woman say say Ronda Rousey right
Ronda Rousey bullying a smaller dude you
can't make the argument that if Ronda
Rousey punished you it wouldn't hurt
anything
yeah how many women that though uh yeah
well you know that's what that's what
I'm saying but it'll be interesting to
see to see how this logic lines up when
you have a woman that's more physically
imposing because I guess the idea with
that video is that the man is obviously
going to be this the more physically
dominant one so he can take he can take
more and whenever he wants to you can he
can finish the situation and so that's
why it's more it's more so would you say
that is a would you say that as a
misandrous type of you no I think it's
just based on reality okay like the guy
like if he wants to beat her up he could
like he's not it's not like it's not
like she's physically stronger than him
it only changes if when you have a woman
he's physically stronger than a man I
would like to see whether Society holds
that up in the same lens like would that
would that be bullying I don't know
um could you say the woman should like
sustain more should be more patient
because the guy is weaker than her and
you know this that would they put the
same responsibility on the woman to be
the more mature more patient kind of
part of you know that that would be very
interesting to me so before it was told
talking about miss Andrew and what it
means like do you I'm saying do you
think that the societies become more
misandrist yeah absolutely because
misogyny has spoken about a lot isn't it
like we speak about misogyny men and
misogynists you know and there's a lot
of talk about misogyny
um when it comes to the whole feminist
movement but I I can see from what I can
see I can see that Miss Andrew's kind of
taken more of a foothold now over
misogyny I can see men
women actually hate in men and hating on
men men are trash men are dogs I'm in a
basement of that like
why are you smiling and laughing what
what do you expect that it's a
consequence of misogyny that's where it
comes from if you take that out of the
equation then you won't get so I don't
think it's as a woman I know for well
uh it wasn't grinding me to hate men but
as you grow up and you see them act a
certain way then you're gonna have an
opinion of them I wouldn't go swimming I
wouldn't go swimming in Australia even
if there was one shark attack I wouldn't
go near it because I know the
consequences but yet as women we're
expected to to still
um trust men that that hurt us
okay what do you mean what do you mean
like what you said what do you what do
you see that bad deal that's so bad well
first of all I said about the domestic
violence and then I think if you look at
like women women do it too no no of
course that men ain't dying at the same
rates so well they can't who's to say
what do you mean who's to say I think
everything that we see is this is what's
given to us as fast we can't take that
as gospel do you know women have diets
no suicide no suicide is is one of the
biggest indicators of our suicide is
relationship conflict or or break up so
you know maybe it's not being logged as
domestic violence but there is
definitely abuse going the other way and
that's a significant part and more women
hit men one-sided than men hit women
one-sided I I struggle I do struggle
with this like I on this on the websites
that I've seen that women are arrested
more for domestic violence than men even
though they suffer more and and like
when in 2000 in 2010 2020 when 110 women
died that year because of that the hands
are male 50 of those deaths were
Overkill which means they killed them
they was there was like brutally kidding
them long before that long after that
110 in London
in the UK that's really not a lot one
every three days you don't think that's
right for the whole year so say from the
whole year yeah from the whole year so
from then to now so say what percentage
of deaths is that that's got to be less
than one percent do you honestly think
that a woman dying every three to four
days is not a lot I don't think it's
like
um I don't think it's like a pressing
like if it's not one of them how do you
know because it's not one of the number
one ways people are dying here
so like like if if we're gonna talk
about if that if that's the big issue
like then we should maybe put obesity
why is it always fat people when that
alcohol is a drug and it's so normalized
but why is the default always fat why is
the default always fat it could be
alcoholism because because that can
because the softer self more people die
what I think what Paul's trying to say
is more people die each year from
self-inflicted things than something
that's been inflicted on somebody else
yeah that does make sense but it doesn't
excuse it do you see what I mean so say
so say when I wouldn't excuse it it's
just putting it into context yeah if you
take if you take a number like 110 out
of a country with like 60 million people
and try and make the case because that's
why well because you're trying to
generalize something about men if you're
gonna if you're gonna make a
generalization about men I want to see
is this prevalent among men is this
really common when you said 110 I'm like
well okay the UK is very populated that
doesn't sound like a lot of people and
when you put it into context but if you
put into context I don't think it's okay
I don't think you do but then if you put
it into context the same amount of women
have died this year right so it's one in
one every three to four days so say from
2020 2021 2022 if you multiply 110
that's free for a year that's close to a
year so our three years there was one
year where a woman was dying every day
that's mad will you put it like that
I don't I don't think it's okay but I
just if I had to guess if I had to guess
I would think that things like car
crashes and obesity would probably be
higher but they're self-inflicted so
that's on them I could walk down the
street and be murdered by a man and and
what did I do to deserve that
why does it have to be a man you could
be murdered but no but I was talking
about that statistic when we're talking
about domestic violence it's it's men
because women my point my point is why
would I make a generalization about men
when it's not a huge percentage of
people that are dying oh okay so hands
have been like from domestic violence I
I well I think that's probably just the
difference in opinion because I think
one every three to four days is what two
a week I think I mean you can you can
manipulate statistics to make them sound
alike it's a lot more prevalent than it
is but but when you when you look at how
many people if I Googled right now how
many people are in the UK is that 60
million yeah 60 million people in the UK
well 110 that's nice that's cool but
then when you put it down to one to
every three to four days that doesn't
and that like I said about one like a
year and that would have been just women
but this is what I'm saying but this is
what I'm saying this is why because
there's a consequence for Action so as
men if you're gonna enable other men and
and whatnot then it's a repercussion
enable other men we just saw in a clip
where when people were attacked when he
was attacking a woman in public people
rushed to her yes how was that enabling
but well the thing is I I understand
that video the video is terrible but
that's just one incident you could film
that tomorrow and and that could be a
different reaction because I personally
have seen free incidences of domestic
violence with a woman being attacked and
I haven't seen it I was the one that
went to see them it was me so I I know
full well that that happens so I'm not
shocked by that video at all because I
don't know what people expect do you
okay do you feel like it's equal like
people protect the genders equally I I
do I do see what the problem with men
but
um in terms of how they're treated in
society but a lot of it are dare to say
that the misandry is almost a bit of a
pity party like if you are someone who's
50 plus about this they ain't got a clue
what you're talking about but they for
the last 50 years seen women go through
this this and this and they're probably
like well of course what did women
really go through can I just ask you
that this okay what do you mean what do
we go through
what do you what do you mean what what
have we gone through I don't know it's a
question you said women have gone
through Justice do you think women are
oppressed no no no oh okay so that's
just that that's just straight off a
completely different opinion and if you
think they are you would have to explain
how they are yeah yeah what do you mean
if they explain how women are oppressed
how how do you think they're not no no
you're answering a question with a
question because like history history
okay if we go back to I I don't know how
old you are but that if we look back to
our Nan 25 25 so that my nan if I go
back to that far she didn't have her own
bank account until her 70s till she till
1970s so she was 60 and how all it is
that in terms of voting work Child Care
order that I don't understand how you
can step back and say no women have got
it all right no but you what you've done
there was conflict to time time like you
were saying 1970s yeah yeah so in the
1970s that may have happened but we're
far from now but yeah we might we're 50
years removed from that but we're asking
you today are women oppressed they may
have been oppressed
women actually weren't oppressed
historically uh I like because even
because I mean a common thing that I
hear women say is like the vote but the
thing is like the only reason we
couldn't vote was because we couldn't be
drafted and so and so like women
historically never had to fight in Wars
we were generally protected where men
were the ones that were sent to war and
had to die in order to build societies
but who started those Wars actually
actually over the last 500 years women
are more likely to wage Wars than men
when women were in positions of power
they're more likely to wage war
um so you could argue that like there
were more men in positions of power
throughout history that's that's true
but the thing is you have to think about
it from a historical context most women
didn't want to be in those roles because
they were very dangerous and people
would die like how many times were
Presidents assassinated et cetera Etc do
you think that that narrative that you
that you're spewing right now has been
quote unquote like we said ingrained
within you
um
I don't think it was ingrained at all I
think it's grown up and being sporty and
and not being taken seriously as the
boys it's it's being harassed on the
tube it's being touched inappropriate
it's been griped it's seen people go
through that it's it's harassed on the
tube I I have if you've been through
that it's an unfortunate thing right
um but if you like at the beginning of
the conversation you you use an idea of
a shark yeah and you said you wouldn't
go to Australia and swim anymore where
there's been a shark so are you now
saying that you wouldn't go anywhere
where there's a man no because I I can't
live like that can I that's not that's
not that's not that car
no I don't drive okay
are you saying that men or you see men
as like Predators generally yeah right
you don't think that that mindset was
voiced upon you you think that's like
just I mean that's personal experience
personal experience 100 I I don't know
how you think that's missandras uh a
little bit I'd imagine it is but again I
think if you was to sit down and talk
and the thing is with women I think the
more experience you've got you probably
have got more of that mindset but at the
same time because certain things have
made you have their mindset you're
always discounted because it's always
it's coming from a certain place like
I'm not silly if something happened to
me and it only happened to me then I
wouldn't have this opinion but when you
see it and when you hear it and then
when you see it and then when you hear
it and then it's in the media and then
it's the mums that you talk to on the
bench and the women at the school and
then you're seeing yeah why I don't know
if like some stories all the time yeah
but I'm not I'm not I'm not believing
someone I've just met do you know I'm
not someone's not coming up
but again these are people that I see on
a frequent basis at the park and at the
school I see their setup so this is the
thing I'm not saying that these things
don't happen I'm saying I think the when
you when you speak the way you're
speaking you said yeah you see men as
Predators I think that's a very
dangerous mindset to have in in this
Society because what it is is that you
are black you are blanketing all men I'm
not as pretty I said to you do you see
men as Predators yeah you said yes so so
I'm saying that that means potentially
there's four predators in this room
right yeah because there's four men in
this room
and if that's the way you've walked in
with that kind of mindset you don't
think that's dangerous you don't think
that's ingrained you don't think that's
inbuilt you don't think you'll pass that
down onto Generations I I think I've
come in here and I've never full that I
was in danger because of the setup but
if I passed you for a man walking down
an Alleyway I would have a different
opinion
do you walk down Alleyways often well
there's free to get onto the estate I
live I've got no choice
it sounds like you're and I don't know
your left you know what I mean I'm not
trying to judge you but it sounds like
you're living trauma no no no it's it's
because I had that I can duck I said to
you if you can have too many things
happen to you and they're isolated
they're not spare enough but if you've
been through that and you see other
people going through that and surely the
best person to listen to is someone like
me that's got the experience yeah I
don't know because I kind of think um
like have you noticed a lot of feminists
that are like very traumatized yeah and
and when you listen to what what they're
traumatized by it seems to be like
everyday occasions they'll be like oh
someone flashed me and I was I was
searching what does that say about
minlin no it just says that you're
fragile and you can't handle basically
being flashed
do you think being flashed is acceptable
but
it's not yes or not acceptable but what
physically happens to you like wow do
you not think that's intimidating I
remember a Story come on I get flashed
sometimes I got flashed in Nigeria am I
in therapy someone showed me your tits
and like a party I didn't even ask I'm
still traumatized
Society needs to change
it's crazy how like we've we've kind of
like we promote this idea of really
fragile people who just like do you know
what could I I'm gonna disagree with you
just for the simple fact I think being
flushed is it's not it's not appropriate
I mean at the end of the day that person
or that individual has gone the issue
that he needs to sort out and he needs
to be addressed personally but I don't
think that should be like it said
blanketed and covered with all men in an
aspect of all men are capable of doing
that therefore I'm not going to go to
certain places walk down certain alleys
yes have your wits about you and have
that and like you know Sarah said it's
it's almost like um
certainly situations have traumatized
you
and therefore you're not thinking
positively
or optimistically on other situations
it's just more narrow-minded
you need to look into why every day such
because situations can traumatize you to
that level where you take on the mantle
of like the noble victim
um consider your mom your grandparents
the kind of stuff they dealt with do you
think do you think they would be
traumatized by the similar kind of
things 100 I don't know how any woman in
this Society isn't to a certain extent
traumatized or doesn't know someone
that's been essayed or great I I don't
have a choice like I've had creepy I've
had creepy things happen to me I'm not
gonna go but but it's a choice whether
to let yourself be traumatized yeah
that's a choice yeah that's a choice if
you let it affect you for years to come
that's a choice it's not a choice but
you're asking me my opinion I didn't
walk in here and I went rude to you
though because you're men because I know
that I I'm not gonna say that like it's
a bad joke
I'm not rude to any man because they're
a man at all but the way you just said
that is like we should be like on a
grateful
I weren't going to come in here and be
rude to you because you're a man that's
what I meant I'm not sure I'm not no no
I'm not rude to anyone find me a man
that I've been rude to and I'll swallow
I just said something yeah I feel like
as I'm I'm only 20 years of age I always
see but I don't I haven't experienced a
lot but I've heard things and seen
things and everything and I don't feel
like I have hatred for men out there
like
I believe it all comes from trauma every
woman has their trauma and their reasons
why they hate men or come across as they
dislike men and can't stand a man do you
know what I mean but I feel like
I have I don't know what it is but I
feel like I have a soft spot for men and
that's why I don't hate them you got me
like you have to be sexual
no
I wouldn't say that you're not
heterosexual no you're a lesbian no
that's yourself straight yeah yeah sorry
sorry sorry sorry okay yeah yeah sorry
yeah yeah I mean like so you are
straight yeah I'm straight okay yeah and
I don't see men doing the same thing to
women like I know men that have
experienced sex so yeah yeah and I know
I have been in domestic violence
situations and they don't look at women
as predators do you I mean that's what I
mean yeah but it's not Arabic it's a
daily occurrences it is for us why do
you not think that though isn't that an
assumption I think it's good because
considering if you were to say it's a
daily occurrence I know these women that
have had this experience we're supposed
to take your opinion and and what you've
heard as as fact but I just think you
can stand here and say I don't think it
happens as frequently to men not being a
man not doesn't mean anything not being
in that space and that's like a valid
statement apparently I don't understand
of course but I think I could tell you
everything that's happened everything
that I've seen everything is and you
would still deny it yeah I'm a woman too
and I could say the opposite
foreign
happens and Essay happens I don't deny
that they happen right my I guess my
issue is the attitude that you have that
spreading that you say I'm not spending
no but you said men are men are
predators you know what I'm saying this
is when you when you say that you like I
said you blank it you blanket men like
that and it's like
um if men grow up this is what we're
talking about missandry if men grow up
in a society where they are demonized
right from the get-go right just Autumn
Academia they haven't done anything you
you as a woman wouldn't like to be
demonized right it's just because you're
a woman
but the way in which we just saw the
video and she wasn't demonized even when
she was but that one video I was gonna
one video but that that there's data to
back that up that men aren't taken
seriously as domestic violence and rape
victims and you just prove that she just
said oh I don't think it really happens
the thing is she said oh men are
predators you don't say no okay sorry so
he just asked me and I just went with
yes over no I like I explained to you I
didn't come up here and think he was
Predator if I saw you at night walking
down an Alleyway I would be scared
so you called him a predator you would
be scared of me I 100 any man I bought
I've lived uh so I've I've had to walk a
lot I don't drive I feel like I'm a nice
kind of guy I don't know that though do
I I don't know you I would feel the same
way if it was a woman well I don't get
that but I feel I feel like you're
you're feeling entitled to feeling to
safety and and the thing is like men
don't feel safe walking alone at night
either but aren't they meant to protect
us
alone if you're walking alone at night I
would argue that women are more likely
to be protected than if another guy is
attacked 100 yeah because if if Sarah
gets punched by some other dude like no
one's coming to see it but it's a man
punching I'll [ __ ] him up man
but it's a man punching you so it could
be I mean look at the video we just
wanted to be innocent it could be
innocent it could be the people have
done this experiment so many so many
times yeah it's very true you could look
up 10 videos about the same exact
experiment with the same exact result
men don't particularly type men
seriously so that's where I find the
problem if I went on not just finish if
I went on Tick Tock and saw a video of a
30 year old teacher that had raped a 13
year old sorry sorry great the the
comments are from men saying oh that's
my Teenage Dream he would have loved
that don't tell me blah blah blah it's
all men saying it's men saying that yeah
yeah but the thing is there are some men
saying that but you're acting as if
there's women as often not as often but
you're acting as if most men are saying
that no no I'm trying to say it's like
not saying the way in which you're
blanket in men right now makes
absolutely no sense it sounds like
you're taking it like I mean you no no
because I no because I asked you I
specifically asked you are do you see
all men as predator
if you say you see all managed Predators
like I said if a man was to say he sees
all women as X he would be called a
misogynist that would be that would be
the the thing that would be leveled at
him so when we say when you say that and
we're talking about Miss Andre versus
misogyny so you you would be a misandras
then I have to agree with you and you
come across as a lovely person and I
think I think you do it unintentionally
yeah is it great you're just brainwashed
I don't think you realize that I don't
think it's bringing all your opinions I
believe it's a lot of trauma I don't
think it's brainwashed I just think it's
unintentional I think it's misdirection
yeah yeah because when I'm listening to
you speak I'm hearing where you're
coming from but I'm also hearing and how
you're following this wrong route and
the mistakes you're making like what's
wrong okay the mistakes you're making is
like he's saying blanketing which is a
good nice word it's basically what
you're doing in your stereotyping yeah
yeah so and I could take offense for the
fact that you've just come in here I'm
not I don't think you have done it
intentionally I can take offense to the
fact that you come in here and say oh
I'm not rooting under you because you
use a lot of men how about you're not
rude to none of us because we're this
normal human being who don't need to be
spoken to in a certain way so it
shouldn't be based on
our sex or you know just the fact that
we're men we're bigger than you and all
these kind of things it should be based
on personal experiences you have
experienced it you need to forgive
yourself and also maybe look at dealing
with that situation properly because you
will spoil a lot of opportunities you
will put yourself in a lot of boxes
narrow off
where you can go to and basically pass
it on unintentionally just how you're
speaking now so what if you switched
what you were saying with race
so what if you were what if you were
going to make generalizations about a
group based on race yeah and say oh oh
but I'm polite to this race can I can I
just can I say something about that
please because that's that's the value
point and I want to say that because I'm
seeing here obviously like um with black
men and a black woman now I I want to
say to you that if your opinion on white
people was she I get where you're coming
from because I've seen the destruction
that white people have caused when we
see Kanye West with all lives matter
that's that argument to me that's a
similar argument because you're American
can you agree to a certain extent what
people say about America because of what
they've done so if you wanna I think
America is great actually oh okay I
think it's a great place to live I think
most people are lucky to come okay well
again I think I grew up so my dad
employed people from India and um they
were very very excited to come to
America there's a lot more opportunity
there than a lot of places in the world
and I think a lot of people in the west
are very spoiled but isn't there a lot
more opportunity for them over here
because of the destruction that's being
close um I would argue I would argue no
than in the UK because I just see the
tax rates you guys have here and a lot
of them are able I want to know what the
point I want to know what a point you
were trying to make is that so okay so
say if I'm on Tick Tock and I'm
scrolling and I see videos of people
slagging off white people so I can
English people blah blah blah I can take
that because there's an element of Truth
there okay because of History
so I don't understand why when you can
look at the statistics of everything and
how men are yeah but imagine imagine but
imagine I walked in here what if we
flipped flipped it what if we didn't use
white people what if we use black people
would it be okay but what do you mean
sorry so what if you flipped it yeah I'm
going to make a generalization about a
group let's say let's say we did black
people would that be okay
um
I know the struggle for women and and
against men okay so I I knew this guy
right this is an anecdotal piece of
evidence I knew this guy that was in
school with me right and he was bullied
in school by some Asian people right
yeah and when he grew up he said I don't
like Asians right however his idea of
not liking Asians right what came from a
minute uh lens that of his own personal
experience and his own personal trauma
so for him to now generalize all Asians
right would be a wrong thing to do now I
don't know your personal trauma I don't
know what you've been through right and
you may have been through some traumatic
things but to generalize all men is the
exact same thing that that guy would
have been doing with the race I think I
think where I went wrong with that is
when you say Predator a hundred percent
it depends on the situation because I'm
not taking that back if I see if I will
pass any of you down in Alleyway there's
going to be a part of me that's going to
be scared okay I'll admit that and
because I see you is that because we're
men yeah that's what I'm saying is that
because I'm black no it's because you're
a man
can I say something that I think will
probably not touching or we'll probably
touch it
um
I guess it's not um you keep referring
back to obviously your personal
experience but talking on others as well
right to back up your story would you
then obviously you said media a lot so I
kind of feel
I don't know shoot me for saying this I
think there's an agenda
to push this to push what
the hatred towards men yeah that's
called violence against women there's
millions of dollars in funding towards
violence against women it's very
profitable too I've never heard of it
yeah it's it's yeah violence against
women is in organizations like women's
organizations that they get millions and
millions of dollars in funding so it's
very profitable for them to spend the
narrative that men are these horrible
people yep so yeah do you think them
because I think there's two there's two
things that I've seen coming up right
like a lot of you said that you know
women weren't are kind of oppressed but
I don't kind of see that I think there's
a lot of opportunity now there's so much
funding going into like sports other
areas as well there's equal
opportunities women are getting big jobs
in you know and to be fair I personally
think a lot of them are they they
deserve the jobs what I will say though
which is quite confusing on the other
hand is I feel like there's this agenda
you say violence against women but I
almost feel like it's to kind of disrupt
homes
um just interested in with that violence
against women thing right I said back to
I said I'll read some statistics again
um back to you from the national Center
of domestic violence right and it says
the types of abuse that men experience
when it comes to women they said they
said 95 of it is emotional abuse 68 is
physical 41 is psychological 23 is
financial 13 is coercive control and
three percent is sexual
[Music]
I had this discussion with my friend the
reason I say this um should be bigger Do
You Believe I'm Gonna I'm just put this
out there for everybody men can be raped
great great oh great
I'm so sorry do you believe men can be
great
um yeah yeah yeah of course
it happens all the time someone someone
doesn't have to just be by a woman by
the way yeah okay
and and I must admit this is another
thing you know women and feminists never
talk about is how like there's a whole
prison population industry where rape is
like normalized it's great great grape
is um but in prison they're being grapes
by men
does that make it okay no but let's talk
in the number so why why is gender why
is gender a crucial part of that
sentence surely you hear a human being
is experiencing trauma in that way and
you want to stop it but your immediate
response is oh it's men doing it no no
because the way
no no it's because it's because the way
you worded it you said oh I'm uh like
women would be surprised to know that
women yeah I'd be surprised no but
there's nothing a woman can do about a
man being raped in prison by a great
imprisoned by another uh
I have a question so if if all men are
predators um would you say that women
are gold diggers with no loyalty and
only want to Rob man of resources while
claiming the victimhood when things go
awry wow that's I think that's a bit
much oh it's much that's a bit much but
but
there's whole Tick-Tock accounts on how
to get money I'm not saying everything
what's that song
I don't think I don't I think if you
look at the statistics of that and in
compare but the thing is I think the
bottom line is great we look great and
people dying
are two different things
second video just but we'll talk yeah go
on I'm just asking would that be a fair
generalization to make about women it is
though that is what it is that is
it's fair you know what I mean the thing
is okay okay it is
it's fair to say that women are gold
diggers with no loyalty and only want to
Rob men out of resources while claiming
victim when things go awry I don't think
that's fair but I think that is the
Viewpoint anyway
you don't believe it's fair no I don't
believe I don't believe what you said
because you've never done it yourself or
I'm not personally a gold digger yeah
and I've never been to Reddit I don't I
don't know you've never seen anything on
Tick Tock of women
okay okay but wouldn't you this is
contradicting everything you said it's
not yeah yeah because you were using
Tick Tock as an example earlier and I
know men are predators and I know women
that are gold diggers but who gets hurt
the most well hang on how do you know
I'm asking you I'm asking you this is
not a comparison I'm trying to see if
you're going to use the same logic that
you used earlier okay and you said it's
not a fair comparison I think that is
the view that you said that's the view
but it's not a fair comparison no but
it's interesting how when the tables are
turned you think it's a fair comparison
[Music]
the whole point is you have a double
standard for men and for women go ahead
I just want to know why you feel all men
are predators I I like I said I I think
it was more in this case if I'm down in
Alleyway to me or the every man in our
party is the president because I've got
a few years
because I've been still done anyways
come on now this is the thing I just
think like why are you why would you I
would never go down an Alleyway alone
how would you get home if that's the
only choice I would just live somewhere
safer so it's my fault I mean I think
you shouldn't put yourself in bad
situations let's be honest let's be
honest this is coming I did not say it
was your fault but I'm just saying wow
you said I should move why would you put
yourself in a bad situation uh like like
men know this they know not to go down
an Alleyway alone at night but women
think we're entitled to safety I just no
I don't think it's we think we're
entitled to no you do because you said
so we once said online supposedly one
safety but you claim that you protected
earlier
okay okay earlier you you said shouldn't
men protect us yes so that therefore
therefore you feel like you're entitled
to safety when throughout all of human
history nobody was entitled to safety
one I think men as as what they want to
be known they want to be known as
protectors so I don't have you ever men
want to be known as protectors to their
women yeah not women they don't know so
you you are single that's why I've
chosen not to get with a man yeah so why
are you entitled to protection from men
that don't know you right coupled with
the fact that you think all men are
predators but after how many times do I
have to repeat myself I said to you all
the depending I said to you numerous
times it is depending on the situation
but the thing is the fact that you said
it is already in there I think because I
was instantly going to walking down
there
do you see yourself getting into a
relationship any time no no
so wow do you know we were sorry we were
talking about earlier on about how the
question you asked about how women view
men or
um or how many humans are as gold
diggers and all that kind of stuff
um there's a video
blessing
um I want you to play that and I'm gonna
get your guys views on it
yeah that one
I can't hear the audience no sir no
sound
nope
oh someone just sent
um a big Super Chat shout out to the
team YouTube gets how much Hearts to
Susan found by some
consonants or Google translate or some
of them video titles are trash I barely
got here right
um also from sentient's feminism and by
extension feminists are all betas of
current Society they're Perpetual
victims when challenged on their views
but preach platitudes while having
undermining motives she and other
feminists are not nice guys no one likes
nice guys
um blast cat Badger she just disgruntled
she is not as pretty as I am cap she
seriously she is very deeply invested in
the agenda that everything and anything
can only be the man's fault at the at
the at can only be the man's fault all
the time sounds like you just don't want
any responsibility or accountability I
just read the big super chats there's
one more you sitting on the couch have
not suffered the same oppression that
our ancestors have you are applying the
sins of our parents onto the current
population immorally and unjustly you
lack forethought to think that most men
are predators and then I'll read the
rest yes
um okay I'll let blessing figure it out
while I'm reading them okay
um guys I'm just doing over ten dollar
super chats today
um NSX question why do you think
institutions and media support missandry
and label anything critical of feminism
as misogyny I.E men's standards wage Gap
myth quotas and only powerful sought
after jobs where does it and American
virus is freedom my ex-wife used to
punch and hit me while yelling back I
saw my dad arrested when I was seven for
blocking a kick from a drunk girlfriend
she fell broke off broke her collar cops
will always arrest the man
um ten dollar Super Chat the worst thing
for society is women having masculine
thoughts and rationalize it using the
feminine logic and male having feminine
thoughts and making
sound logical using male rationale on
control F I ran on any News homepage you
will get one hit if you're lucky where's
all the Western feminists when needed
answered screening about 950k arguably
pointless operations annually oh
abortions annually in the U.S because
you've never respected him in the first
place
you got a blessing okay um I was gonna
read the rest of my Instagram
um if only 20 of men are getting 80 of
the women how do you push the idea of
the of men are evil the same guys women
keep picking how about opening the pool
rather than blaming all of us for the
few please look up The Selective Service
benefits and penalties webpage and read
it men still don't have rights in the
USA without signing up
um and then
the modern feminist is simply
Schrodinger's cat experiment empowered
winners since them are a victim when it
suits them sorry her
um a woman's fear has been monetized by
the media and feminism telling them to
fear everything a man does including
existing
um 50 50
that okay that's all though yeah
yeah I actually saw something on Tick
Tock
um a man he went to go see his daughter
I think him and his partner split up and
they've been in like Arguments for like
months or whatever and he went to the
house and she attacked him and she he
called the police on her and they
arrested him yeah I mean because men are
automatically are the aggressors
as well like if you call about someone a
woman abusing you they'll they'll they
see me all the one abusing so it's like
a it's in there like terms of stuff like
that is how they trained
um yeah I know Australia is also another
place where they're considering um
giving boys vasectomies I feel like what
these things yeah so they say they say
instead of birth control and condoms and
all this stuff that since men have you
know more sperm that boy should just
have beef have false vasectomies in
school that's the dumbest thing and they
talk about my body my choice but they
never talk about men don't have the
right to choose when it comes to
Selective Service in the U.S so they're
they're forced to be drafted if we ever
went into a war situation and they have
no choice over their body well I would
like to point out
um just for people who like the way I
look at things it's how I process what
she's saying is you notice like she
keeps on mentioning this Alleyway kind
of scenario you think it's kind of
interesting that in the media when
people kind of portray rape it's
normally in the alleyway great
great portray this kind of stuff it's
normally in the alleyway anyway
the majority of it it's programmed isn't
it it's scary people watch these same
videos especially the feminists they
watch these same videos they get these
same narratives and then in real life
they act like they live in Alleyways and
that this is like a scenario that
actually happens by ease yeah but the
thing is your Mo you're most likely to
get graped not in an Alleyway by
somebody that you know of course yeah
your partner right so what so why that
anyway analogy is what is what you're
saying Alleyways at night it's because
she I think she lives where she lives
you're you're 32. and yeah so you can't
pick somewhere that's not down in
Alleyway is there not a cost of living
crisis or do you honestly think it's
that easy to pick up and move you could
move into a cheaper area outside of the
city there's always Solutions
okay you're telling me the only houses
that you could live in are down dark
alleyways
in all of wherever you live whatever
town you live in the only places that
you could pick to live you have to go
down dark alleyways
what is this wow does that make any
sense it doesn't that's yeah what do you
mean so every time as a woman we buy a
house we've got scope the area to check
with it anyway yeah if I live but why
don't men just stop stalking me okay if
I I no I live I I live there's no
there's no guy that lives here and one
of my requirements when looking at
apartments was I need a front desk
person because I I want security because
I don't want to be in a dangerous
situation
um sorry I put off saying it because I'd
imagine I'm in Council so I didn't ever
say where I got but do you know you know
what you just said which was very
interesting he said why don't guys stop
stalking yeah right you know Society
doesn't you know yeah exactly you know
because
people get told not to do things all the
time we get told not to steal we get
told not to murder I mean we get told
not to group we get tons to a lot of
things people still do it so because we
know people still do it right now it's
time for you as a person to take to take
it on yourself to say I know people do
this let me put myself in a position
where I'm mostly least likely to have
that affect me because people out there
still like I've got a car should I have
a car without an alarm and a mobilizer
no no but I can say people shouldn't
steal cars of course I should say people
should steal cars but they do so I've
now got to protect myself from the
people that do still cost so this is one
of the things about um self-agency and
being like accountability for yourself
and I'm not saying that people should
not or people should be graped and
people should be essayed but I'm saying
there are situations in their scenarios
like Pearl was saying that you can put
yourself in or not put yourself in to
make that more likely to happen to us so
do you do anything to prevent like of
course I switch up the way I walk home
there's so to to walk back into my
estate there's two Alleyways or it would
be like a 45 minute walk around the
whole way okay I switch on my routine
every time I walk I I've been watching
crime documentaries from along a young
age no no no but that's the truth that's
the truth though isn't it it's just what
is is true but you know so everything
goes of course but it's not just it's
not just women being killed by men but
the thing is that I find when I watch
these documentaries where women are are
being killed by men is that there was
numerous numerous numerous numerous
chances to nip in the bud or put him
away for life before it got to the
chance he killed someone can I ask you
something that's literally with like
every murder every every decision yeah
of course so so why is it like just just
we were talking about that that's the
same with every crime it should be the
same with every crime you should get you
should get a sentence that reflects the
crime and you shouldn't be allowed to go
out and recommit I think I was going to
ask you something you said you watch a
lot of um crime crime stuff I kind of
feel like
it kind of feeding into it you're
feeding into the trauma you're feeding
into the paranoia instead of taking
accountability okay there's certain
things you you have a choice on what
you're putting into your Consciousness
yeah because you also have a choice of
where you walk and where you go I've
also got you know female friends who
take precautions you know they send
their live location they avoid certain
places they stay on the phone to me or
they they just don't go home at a
certain time I do understand that not
everybody has the same form of a you
know advantages or whatever but there
are things that you can do to adapt to
the situation and when I look at you and
I listen to you like I keep on saying
this is all a case of you not riding you
know broadening your horizons in terms
of understanding we all know that people
do bad things in different situations
but what are you doing to prevent that
and protect yourself without having a
hatred for that one particular thing
and like do you think that's like this
is the reason why I'm having this
conversation the reason when we're doing
this in a great area because I think
that that's psychology that you have is
becoming more and more prevalent men are
just being seen as automatic Predators
but they're just being seen as automatic
bad guy and it's like not a good one no
but there's a reason you need men though
I never said I never said we didn't know
I'm not saying what I'm saying Society
needs men so to paint men in a bad light
consistently and continuously what it's
going to do to men is at some point when
they're gonna be like oh well if you see
us as such bad people you know what you
look do it yourself it's a good man
built the world for us and you're
[ __ ] on them as a thank you right do
you think can I ask you a question do
you look around the world as like in
terms of wars that are happening the
abortion rights they've been taken away
from women that over in Afghanistan with
with their girls not allowed to go to
schools and they're being married off do
you honestly think the world is a nice
place to live right now I think that the
world we have the lowest poverty rate
ever in human history but that doesn't
in the West in the west we are not
oppressed at all yeah at all as women
who we have every single right you could
possibly want
the thing is you said do you think the
word is best is it good yeah I think
it's better than it was 500 years ago of
course but I still I mean it's good yeah
but it's better than it was 500 years
ago 400 years I think the world is a
great place to live I don't understand
that question do you think the world is
a good place because oh because Paul
said there are men created this world
for us and I'm sure oh oh so your
question was because the world sucks I'm
saying
you have more safety than ever than
women ever did like living being a
single woman is a privilege yeah like
you historically could not do that
because you would need to be protected
from other men or other Predators right
yeah and so men built this world where
they're the police officers or the
firemen they build the buildings or the
engineers they're the plumbers they're
the electricians 95 Plus
and as a thank you you call them all
predators again you could not live the
way you live without without men because
if you cool the police
it's gonna be a man most of the time you
you want a woman turning up when you're
in trouble
um I I um I don't have any faith in the
police no I wouldn't call them and let's
see it was like
desperate like I genuinely thought my
life was going to end it was in seconds
well it depends situational
um I don't know someone's breaking into
your house
what are you doing oh I suppose in those
cases but when it is
so their life is in danger who are you
calling I don't trust them okay who who
are you calling I'll have to call them
but I don't trust them it doesn't seem
like you trust many people
um I don't see why people do if I'm
honest I don't look around and see much
not joy in the world there's plenty of
joy in the world there is I'm not going
to see her and say there isn't however
there's there's a massive problem when
it comes to certain things classes and
racism misogyny homophobia they they're
all interlinked they're all [ __ ]
I don't think they're all problem with
that I think I think you go on Tick Tock
and you watch videos no I've got my
brain and I open my eyes complaining
about the same things so for example
homophobia homosexual people are like
two percent of the population
okay so what does that mean that they
don't need to protect you so the idea
that this is like some massive problem
is like what it don't matter I'm the
first to start off they're literally
like a minority of a minority that's
true and then on top of that gay men
like they're all predators as well not
they're one of my best Mates is gay
but he he's
why would he be a predatory yeah no I
understand what you're saying back to
what other men but I'm talking I'm
talking about that as as a woman do you
see what I mean like in terms of again I
can't say all men but this is the thing
that I think I think I wish I would
could rewind myself because I would love
to know what you was coming up with now
because I've I've explained myself
numerous times what I should have said
to your question when you said do I see
men as Predators what I should have said
is situational okay so maybe if we go
from then then it's a different thing so
in certain situations I I would see all
men as a predator 100 yes in certain
situations I would see it
situations
I think more women alone on the tube
alone on the bus I don't think I think
more women are predators than men I do I
do Street interviews at night and I'm
much more afraid of getting attacked by
a woman than a man because if anything
if I'm attacked by a dude another dude
will come help me I I the only time I've
ever been scared of getting like punched
or had someone attack me it was a woman
that's fair that's your experience mine
would be a man so there would gonna come
from different angles aren't we
this is very interesting I'm a blessing
um that second video is it okay to play
thank you let's play this and see we'll
see what you guys think it is
oh [ __ ] them [ __ ] their feelings why the
[ __ ] would we respect man
they're like there are Predator like
they're literally if we were put out in
nature they're the ones we should fear
oh my God this woman's dog definitely
stepped on a bee so I don't know if you
know this but we are in nature this is
not a simulation and most men are not
preying on anything except for Little
Caesar's extra most bestest and the
Gargoyles and Eldon ring but I'm gonna
let you finish
them if I can get like their wallet to
be empty and mine and empty their
pockets [ __ ] yeah I'll take it
reparations [ __ ] also like when I was
making the mistake of [ __ ] men I
didn't hear what they wanted to say I
didn't want to listen they're dumb I
don't respect them when I would make the
mistake of [ __ ] them I would
literally cover their mouth because I
was like Boo Boo I don't give a [ __ ]
you're a piece of meat for me let's get
this over with because I need to you
know you need to make me not finish so I
can finish Thee I swear they are finding
the most creative ways to tell on
themselves this isn't even like if you
squint you can kind of see the predatory
behavior it is right there it is a giant
red flag Factory and it's almost like
she realized how bad it sounded at the
end of the year she started stuttering
hurry up and make me not finish so I can
finish being here like I guess at least
you don't respect yourself either
everything she just described about her
own behavior is her being the predator
and then look at this follow-up clip why
would I willingly let a man into my life
so I need to be [ __ ] over so I can be
manipulated Oh you mean exactly the
thing that you said you do to men you
really managed to wrap up that
projection in a pretty little bow didn't
you and they all love to justify this
with the whole well mended at first so
that's the only reason I'm doing it
thing the whole Chicken and the Egg
thing doesn't matter because you're both
chickens like do you see what I'm saying
here if your response to seeing people
behave like Monsters is to become a
monster you're not a better monster and
I'm gonna be very real with you if you
are indeed covering a men's mouths
during intercourse against their consent
to silence them I hope you get slapped
with every essay conviction in the book
Something tells me you going to prison
would be a win-win for all of us you can
finally be in a place where there are no
men and men can be in a place where
they're safe from predators like you
scary jeez
that is actually scary why it's not
scary it's funny scary okay I just say
scary all the time tonight
it's just scary how
women are actually Predators them so you
got me like that is actually a predator
right there that's Basics man yeah
you're gonna see some real Predators I'm
talking alien V Predator Predators like
they can go invisible with stuff
yeah what did you think of the stuff she
was saying like about how she feels
about me
because
a lot like I'm still processing it I
never knew women actually no I did know
but to that extreme covering a man's
mouth and
in the most that's great
yeah she definitely has a therapy so
I've said right that's all I thought
she's paying someone a lot of money
just so that they could not finish how
comes that's still on Tick Tock as well
because it's okay to say stuff like that
about yeah it's not and it's and and you
can cancel Andrew take like right now
like feminism is a hate group and and we
haven't treated as a head group so we've
normalized it so that's like our default
message
um and everything you know outside of
that is obviously well I've said that a
lot of feminists have chosen to become
just like some of the worst types of men
in history yeah but you know what I mean
it's like there's been really bad men in
history but what you've done to say oh
my thing is to get even with men and
become just like like she said just like
the monster they want to become like the
worst types of an in history and they
think that's quote unquote equality
yeah they're taking that power back I've
feminists have said that to me at one
point I said something like taking that
power back yeah it's like oh and this is
funny all right this is this is when I
saw the timeline of a feminist and I
always loved when I did this this was in
uni this is the Cambridge girl and it
was interesting because she was gorgeous
and you know she cheated on her
boyfriend she spent a lot of time
justifying it and I had it I was just
observing her and at one point
um she was talking about taking her
power back by like treating men a
certain way and it was interesting
because I actually met her like later on
in like later 20s
um so it's funny to think that she was
telling me how in uni like should go
back with guys and like she wouldn't
sleep with them because she thought it
was like her being powerful and like you
know exercising her right of consent
it's funny seeing her like that woman
they feel like
being squared up with men is doing
something to the men when they don't
understand how they're just bringing
down us women she blew board she bought
these guys for fun played played with
expectations wasted their nights and she
she
thought well you know I can say yes or
no she took pride in that right oh wow
so it was funny to meet her later in her
20s having difficulty attracting those
men she was telling me like yeah it's
definitely different now it was one of
the most fulfilling wholesome moments of
our relationship was like yeah yeah what
are you having sex with her no after
that just hearing hearing these
conversations you know you know pillow
talk you're like yeah I'm sure you've
got all that now yeah and she knows she
knows she was being dumb but like you
know you know they can't they can't
process things consciously so like you
say something and you can see in the
corner of her eyes that like she kind of
understands that and then the feminist
program and kicks it back in again and
it's kind of like no but better man have
you guys met or dealt with misandrists
women who you know that you know they
actually don't like men yeah and for the
women have you actually deal dealt with
men who you know are misogynists and
they don't like women
yes no
no
no you said no oh yes who may yeah yeah
yeah 100 okay why would you why why or
did you find out at a later stage what
the message
um I think he I don't think it's so much
relationships it's more like friendships
or men I've seen or or men down the pub
and that sort of that sort of thing you
know no when I say deal with them in a
relationship with in a situationship
with oh yeah I think it's come from in
relationships 100 but I just thought you
meant that in a general term I mean I
dealt with a
lady who was a very anti-man right she
always believed that I mean her
experiences and when she used to talk
about the partners she had been with it
was trauma
continued on on and on and when it came
down to me I'm supposed to take it all
right and then when I stood up for
myself right I was seen as the
narcissist right I was seen as the
aggressor right I was seen as I don't
have a voice because I'm tough I'm big I
meant to take it all
the the effects of that the emotional
effects of that were quite long-lasting
because it kind of built a hatred within
me right I wasn't heard
I wasn't um allowed to have an opinion
because like I said I'm a man right
um did you react did I ever react to her
I mean there are times when it got very
very heated
but I wouldn't definitely I wouldn't say
I reacted in a way that was can be
deemed as uh how did that make you feel
in terms of like
are you traumatized by I wasn't
traumatized but it definitely made me I
went through the motions of blaming race
first I would never date these okay you
go through the motions oh I'm never
gonna get with a person that's not fully
over and then I also had to look at
myself because before you blame anybody
you've got to start with yourself right
I you attract what you are so they say
so I started thinking to myself maybe
she I was attracted
to this person because I'm probably
traumatized from something right then I
also had to question myself on oh maybe
I ignored these signs because of how
attractive she was
and you know I can take it because I
started to believe into that notion of
I'm a man I'm strong I'm this I'm that
but in fact what I was doing was
juggling everyone's emotions and
ignoring my own and it ended badly we
tried back and forth
you know we we considered um
canceling
um canceling
yeah we considered that and you know
what it was I mean when we eventually
went our bad way uh our separate ways it
was the case of
He's the bad guy
step four ghost yeah I never I never
listened you never listened to my
feelings you never listened to my
emotions
and then obviously you you as a man
where we are we are pictured or we're
painted in this thing or we're not meant
to talk too much we're not supposed to
express ourselves too much because what
we do we're seen as the weaker I feel
like a lot of women go into relationship
traumatized by their ex or their past
everybody does yeah puts it on to the
man and that's why you may feel that way
do you think it's like whip its own
fault though because we we pick bad guys
right I mean yeah but you can't tell
them that right they hate it they hate
it because like women women
um felons have 30 more kids than
non-felons yeah so it's like it's like
girl's a little screamer the trauma but
it's like [ __ ] true you picked a trauma
there was Joe down the street
my Skies someone gave me disability I'm
gonna try and explain it as best as
possible someone said there's a
difference between a good guy and a nice
guy no there's no difference no there is
a difference according to I hope I do
you proud she knows who she is a nice
guy is the one that really over
compensates for what you've lost in
previous situations yeah yeah roses the
whole shebang overdose and the good guy
is someone who can put you in your place
he's not but you know he's not the softy
he's he's about that life if that makes
sense you know they're called the nice
guys because women do actually
like them do you know what I mean as in
oh he's a nice guy yeah he's not with me
yeah
a woman will call a man a nice guy
because they're not attracted to them
like they they don't see themselves with
them like you can be a nice guy I mean
you can be a good guy
but a nice guy to someone else you know
what I mean because you're not attracted
to that person if that makes sense
that's what you would break it down to
yeah because you're not attracted to
that nice guy that is that's not your
fit so that's exactly so would you
so you saying women don't want nice guys
no they do yeah they want a good guy but
not a nice guy isn't because they're not
attracted to that person so it's
basically what I'm saying literally want
a guy that doesn't exist yeah they want
the perfect mix they want an alpha now
that secretly like some kind of feminist
after yeah
please lead me I respect your decisions
and everything I just I just want to be
under you that's what they want they
just want you to lay down because that
girl said cover your mouth you may not
be like attracted to them but they might
be giving you everything you want so
that's why they call them the nice guy
do you know what I mean rather than you
using them right yeah
don't get it twisted women like this is
I've had a few friends like you know
normally the emotional [ __ ] kind of guys
that say stuff like this like I'm a nice
guy that's not a compliment what you're
saying is you're you're so weak that
you're dating strategies be to be so
overly like nice and you put yourself in
a situation where like women women know
what you're doing in it like she thinks
you're lame is a nice guy she thinks
you're lame as hell like women tell me
this is like your name as hell bro but
you're being nice so I can't I would be
like critique you because that would be
mean yeah that's what they mean it's a
mad insult never think of yourself as a
nice guy the good guy be a good guy no
just be just be a Savage Be an Effective
man
wait
who's this one you need to be okay
assertive let's pull it down because
women respect masculine men they don't
respect like you and I was listening to
you being tongue-in-cheek but when you
said the nice guy thing women like
masculine men they don't wear nice guys
like you said so what do you call 30
more 30 more you know guys and Felons
have have children
um and and not only that you guys guys
have seen guys have experienced women
and they know that when they've been
overly nice
it's not really worked well in there
they don't work yeah it don't work if
you can tell a man to
I don't know go on so if you can tell a
man to like shut up and he shots up
that's enough
but that's what big class as a nice guy
literally it's true like girls actually
a massive girls actually class masculine
men as men that can put them into their
place
where's your brain at
right and you tell me Shut up and I'm
like don't you ever talk to me like you
shot that beat how I feel because that's
me checking you
according to your
bubble guys checking is feminine why are
you why are you out here I'm just I'm
just asking women yeah
that's feminine as hell it's not going
to get toxic yeah and he's like that
isn't that it's going to get toxic isn't
it just going to become an argument wait
wait wait before we get there how about
feminine checking someone this is
feminine y'all here playing Tit for Tat
with women right no she's gonna say this
and then I'm gonna say this is going to
put on it no no no no no no pick your
balls up no no and walk out the room no
no I don't I don't engage him back and
forth we people it's not about that it's
a it's a form it's a it's a it's a thin
line of this it's a thin line of respect
at the end of the day what you allow
will continue
if if a woman tells me to shut my mouth
I would tell her very quickly there and
then never let that happen again that's
it I won't tell her shut up because I
just gave him a scenario me checking her
is me telling her my boundaries right
that's right don't cross that boundary
again that's it simple that's not
checking that's just I'm proud of my
boundaries and if you're not going to
respect them I respect my boundaries and
if you don't respect my boundaries then
we're not compatible that just sounds
very feminine yeah like no no no no no
no no I like it I don't I don't know you
I don't know I don't know like like you
gotta let me finish damn it's just the
way the way you're talking like like
that sounds like a woman like when you
say oh I need you to respect my
boundaries like women say that no it's
usually after years of therapy see why
does it
you thought black woman as well when you
were talking before about how like men
expect women expect you not to speak and
Etc to me you sounded like a woman you
sound like a it's very interesting you
know what it is all right look I I'm
very sure of myself so your opinion is
your opinion I appreciate them do I
agree with them no
um what I will say though it's it's very
interesting to hear the opinion on your
personal at all no no that's fine it's
fine listen listen if you know me you
know me if you don't know me then that's
good for you but one thing I will say is
anybody that's able to speak on their
points of views in terms of different
situations that's them you can't bracket
it or pull it in a place that sounds
feminine so if I if I want to tell
someone respect my stuff I'll tell you
what I think this is a feminine strategy
right it's not really no no you use the
definition go ahead when when you when
someone says something that kind of like
contradicts you you change definitions
so now you've just said
which is which is a women's kind of
strategy in in a debate and discussion
well bro I like what you're doing but I
I find it very interesting so it's it's
very very simple for me it's not about
changing the words it's not about that
it's what I believe is my amendment to
have balance so men I'm allowed to okay
so what you're basically saying is if
somebody now comes to me and does
something I don't like it's feminine
yeah no no no no no no here we are
there's the problem hold on hold on hold
on it's feminine for me to stand up and
say don't do that
okay I just think it's like feminine to
argue back like I think like but it's
the same way there's a difference
okay look look I I like I like this
because it's all about opinions right I
hate what you're saying it is quite
is unmanly to argue with a woman right
back right but at the same time that
doesn't mean as a man you shouldn't be
able to tell somebody what your
expectations are
okay I think the thing is the more you
talk the more you sound like things I've
heard women say and I'm just we've been
that's interesting then I'll leave it
like that I'll leave it for the people
to decide can I can I just say something
I say if you're not allowed to say your
boundaries say you're in a relationship
and she's going at you but you can't say
excuse me then then isn't that a bit
domestic violence and is that is that
not what we're talking about please
don't be a victim now like no I don't
want to see you get that permanent I
don't want I don't want my man to be
like yeah I was a victim of something no
but do you do you do you see what I'm
saying if you're kind of making out
there him saying these are my boundaries
please respect them is feminine
everyone's going to have boundaries wait
so men not mental boundaries no do you
know what it is
I'm interested I tell you what it is I
tell you what it is calm down every week
Weekly right and for me weekly for Pearl
like four days a week right we speak to
women on the show yeah and we have heard
repeated lines throughout this six seven
months that we've been doing this right
and one of them is respect my boundaries
is a very it's like a very feminine
thing to say so it's like when you hear
a man say it it's like this is the first
time I think I've heard a guy say that
okay cool so allow me to allow me to
because you like you've got there's a
there's now context to it it's because
you've been hearing a certain pattern
from from women from women yeah so maybe
there's not enough men that's speaking
about I like the fact that we have
different opinions ourselves but me I I
take pride in respect I feel like that's
no I feel like that
I feel like what he's saying is key like
for a man and a woman to get along
there's boundaries and their principles
both men and women should have
boundaries and no one should cross the
boundaries once you've crossed the
boundaries the man has the right to
leave leave or the woman has the right
to leave do you go I mean you both have
boundaries in a relationship
I think to say is yeah all right let me
let me accurate Define
all the ways that was feminine exactly
why so so firstly us men were physical
creatures in it women women engaged with
the world through through communication
because they're not as physical they're
not strong they can't assert themselves
physically you're just black boxing
yourself
from what you're saying why we say it
sounds like how a woman would speak is
you talking back asserting your
boundaries by basically talking back
which is essentially asking or trying to
tell someone is is very feminine because
a man I just I just assert my boundaries
I don't ask it's not a check checking
kind of thing another way that was
feminine is framing so I noticed when
you're talking about the experiences in
relationship you you framed it the way
you talk is like you are you are like a
victim of this woman and like you are
asked for permission you said stuff like
oh I wasn't allowed to do this you know
I wasn't allowed to do that she didn't
treat me like this that which sounds
like you're a victim of the situation
which is unlike a man because you can't
be a victim of a woman because I can
always choose to where to spend my time
on energy so that that's where the
complete difference is that's normally a
female kind of talking Frankie pattern
thank you can I can I address that back
yeah I think it's quite sad that your
perspectives of communication between
one person to another person is defined
by sex
now
should I watch should I roll around with
like a caveman and throw my fists around
or should I ghost somebody without
telling them why I have the option
see I have an option
I have a choice I have free will I don't
follow no one's doctrines or principles
so you calling a family maybe you're the
feminine guy because you don't know how
to communicate sufficiently and tell
some of the boundaries listen I get a
crack what happened let me let me finish
let me finish I can get it cracking
anywhere else inside That's The Power of
free will right if I decide on back to
that personal thing I give a bit of
myself because I'm confident now
talking on that situation I I said I
wasn't allowed doesn't mean I didn't do
I was just giving you an example of the
question that he asked I was given a
fair example and a justification and how
the knock-on effects from that
individual played upon me I'm Not Afraid
yeah go on what would you do in that
situation if I got her to shut up would
you shot I would look at her for about
five to seven seconds again that's
femininity I'll give her an opportunity
to reconsider that course of actions
yeah I don't I don't need to I don't
need to I used to do this when I was
younger every boy learns this when
you're younger my mom used to say stuff
my sister used to say stuff and I
noticed if you start talking back you
get into this feminine state where now
you're both waffling and back and forth
arguing they don't respect you they
don't care what you're saying anyway so
as as men normally learn that like the
most important to do with these
situations is not to start talking in it
like I'll let you decide and then if if
you're still being annoying and rude
then you know I'll just walk away and I
don't ask there was no permission and
you have no control over anything I do
let me let me say one of them and no one
ever crosses my boundaries
actually I think the best way to control
silence that's right and taking away I
hate that yeah
you know yeah because it drives you nuts
exactly it's bad right when a guy argues
with you
like the attention you want let's try
like if a guy just walks away I think
that's that's like torture and this is
what okay let me just say let me just
say so I've been in like a few
long-term relationships right and this
is what I realized with the whole
quote-unquote boundary swing before
things even get there they're a
conversate for me there are
conversations that I had between the men
and the um woman and you kind of
I guess you flesh out what what type of
person you're with right and so I know
if
if you were saying if a woman told me to
shut up I know if she got to that point
where someone shut up she would have
known that was the wrong thing to do
anyway so like Powell said that once I
want and also as you said she's helped
me to shut up I'm gonna look at you for
a while and be like
really it's awkward okay that's where
we're going and and the thing is my my
next response is not going to be the
response it's going to be yours because
the way I look at you you're gonna know
that you've done something wrong do you
know what I mean and then so for me it's
like we can either I'm not gonna do that
back and forth and I could probably I'll
probably leave
or just no I I wouldn't I don't engage
in arguments with women like that okay
it's hellof I don't yeah I don't I don't
want engagement why does it have to be
classified as an argument right see what
I get what you're saying the kind of the
concept you're putting in is arguments
that status like it's not it's a
conversation so all he could say is
don't talk to me like that conversation
ended
up at the same time at the same time I
get what you guys are saying and I'm
taking it I do understand where it comes
from and it's a it's a point of view
that one I respect it but what I would
say is that
there are times where people don't know
where they're going wrong regardless of
your the context of how long you've been
together or in the open discussion you
had in that moment in time
emotions from both sides are high people
say from my side fine you might be a
cool Collective character yeah not
everything not everything is always
going to be like that I'm not gonna lie
I'm a bit more stoic as well like when
it comes to like arguments like I'm kind
of more cool and calm and kind of chill
you should be yeah but at the same time
what if she now ask you where did I go
wrong are you not gonna have the
conversation she would never ask you
that you'd have to have these
conversations but there are some people
that don't see where they go wrong I
think I think you're convincing yourself
that there's a reason for this course of
action and I don't think it actually
exists
this is what people do right you have
you have these back and forth
conversations and a lot of women will
convince themselves that like some
question was asked and that's why this
this discussional argument is escalating
and going to reason where it is and you
know if you actually are in these
situations have you heard a couple fight
argue like like aggressively and it just
drags on and on and if you listen to
them you're like this conversation could
have stopped like 30 minutes okay yeah
yeah okay no but you said my dog is the
reason
let me give you something to think about
you say that your approach is to keep
smiling and walk away right
something like that okay something like
that so what happens you just pick up
where you left off yeah when you get
back to talking no I just I just carry
on they will stop talking hold on you
say I'm gonna say it again so you ghost
or whatever you call it cut the line cut
all forms of communication right and it
gets awkward in the house everyone hold
on hold on so the silence just however
long it needs to be yeah so when it the
conversation starts again are you just
picking up from where you left off
before the situation no I don't I don't
pick up so what happens
I come back and well depending on
whether that the conversation was based
on a point where she making a point was
I making a point but what is it why does
that not have to be like what you're now
making excuses for no it's not an excuse
me it is because your doctrines was I
cut the conversation there's no context
because when I gave you a story
communication
I'm gonna listen to you I just want I
just want to break something very very
great TV go on you said when when I was
talking I was trying to make it out like
a victim right
but you said bear in mind we've just had
a talk about domestic violence when when
you was talking about
um your boundaries you said men can't be
victims of women
and we and well an hour ago we was
talking about how domestic violence with
men is not taken seriously and you say
something like that
yeah
I saw your whole sorry your whole 15 30
minutes was a contradiction yeah 100 so
so obviously in reality um this is
reality a woman can stop a man Etc
there's cases like that but I generally
believe a masculine man a healthy
masculine man with a strong mindset
cannot really it's it's there's very few
cases where a man like that can be a
victim of a woman because you always
have agency and power of yourself or
you're never going to be the less
dominant I'm gonna address you what's
your name because I'm gonna address you
Alex Alex you're nice to meet you man
this is bro the way you're talking like
I got into this lady about the way she
was throwing certain words and the
blanket in the way you're saying is a
healthy healthy listen men can be
affected just like anybody else through
violence mental other things don't be so
naive and be so strong-headed that
you're not open to other points of views
that now it's a case of a healthy man
bro are you telling me that when I was
in that situation I'm not a victim I
wasn't healthy
in your in your situation yeah because
what sounds unhealthy because you were a
victim I was not a victim I told you I
wasn't a victim you're the one that
blanketed it so so what are you so what
you're saying is so yeah I said no frame
it like you're a victim there's no
framing I told the story you took it
like that how would you digest certain
things is up to you
yeah but you're saying something that's
self-evident okay I'm gonna ask you a
question did you take it like I was
playing a victim let's let's not follow
that I just want to ask you Jesus do you
believe reminds me of I was arguing with
myself we're not arguing we're having a
discussion no but let's go back to that
initial conversation you said we will go
back to it but I'm asking a question do
you feel when I [ __ ] I'm listen there's
no right no wrong I feel this is great
I'm not gonna laugh I want to ask you a
question do you personally feel what I
gave you a scenario was that me trying
to play a victim
in a way I would say yeah
you didn't you didn't
stay you may say you basically made you
the topic you never stayed the other
woman's
you know her how she felt in this
situation or you know she's not here to
talk about it I'm talking about an
experience she wasn't here the question
is from I respect your opinion I'm gonna
take it that's fine but I just wanted to
ask a question and everybody's entitled
to the answer yeah I think right okay so
let's go back to that point where you
said that woman is rude to me
um you know she says me shut up shut up
Alex or whatever uh I I I kind of cut
the conversation short I come back
you're saying do I restart that
conversation Etc do you know do you
continue like nothing or continue from
yeah so do I restart it from where we
ended or you know go through another
path I asked I said well it depends on
what purpose the initial conversation
had if she brought something up and that
conversation was based on how she felt
then I think it's her responsibility to
restart the conversation because it's it
serves her if it was something I brought
up and I wanted to address then normally
I wouldn't I wouldn't I feel like the
disrespect is enough of an answer
I get what he's saying I get what he's
saying but doesn't that doesn't sound
like more tactical oh she's the one
that's enrolled so I'm gonna allow her
to reunit if you wanna but that's how
logic works you know if someone has an
issue and we have a discussion and then
they're rude then I cut off that
conversation because I don't I don't
engage in rude and you know
disrespectful conversations if you still
want to meet that point then it's your
problem that's why you started the
conversation
that's not Tit for Tat I'm interested to
what I'm going to ask you why okay cool
I wouldn't classify myself a massage
interest but if I if I've got traits or
I display something that's fine each to
their own right what you're saying is
fine and that's your method of dealing
you keep on you keep on starting like
you know different experiences you you
keep on saying because I'm open to
everybody's opinion and you keep on
saying things that should be
self-evident so this this is a great
example of how Society is now feminizing
men this idea that like we men are
encouraged to take on this victim mantle
and even start to speak like women so
that's the thing I hear a lot of women
say they'll be like okay that's your
opinion you're a different person have
you not seen okay this is this is what's
wrong with that though no no no because
that's because it's self-evident no hold
on hold on I don't need to tell you that
that's your opinion obviously it's your
opinion I just heard you say it it's
fine it's it's um it's deeper than me
and you but one thing I'll say this is a
perfect example someone that's
intimidated who feels the need to speak
about their masculine the masculine side
by trying to put down another man's
opinion because jokes and eyes are not
the same that's toxic it's toxic
masculinity that's exactly what's just
happened what I will say is I'm not
offended by your statement but the fact
that you keep on trying to bring me out
and call me out then boy I must be
intimidating you in some way because I
deal with things in a different way than
you do
you guys need to straighten them is that
what it is you're intimidated by me oh
no
I will say wholeheartedly no that's what
the girls said trust me about that it's
too deep it's actually okay you know
what look look I would love for someone
in the Super Chat to have have an
opinion because I'm very interested but
one thing I will say it's actually about
to yeah
um this is just it was a 50 one I try to
read those quicker Jesus
um how is a man demanding respect from
his woman feminine if a woman keeps
telling her man to shut up and the man
says nothing she will only get more
aggressive communication is a big part
of relationship see so a man saying
nothing is illogical and beta
um okay that I was just cool so so like
I said it's it's like I said nothing is
going to change my path on the way I
think right we're all coming all from
different you're open-minded
I'm very open-minded but it seems like
you're close-minded to the sense now
you're picking that's quite feminine
[Music]
um
what was the statistics about men going
um
psychological abuse yeah abused about a
woman
um emotional or psychological physical
physical
abuse if you are you personally but if
every man went about how you went about
and just took words from women in that
abuse no because I said communication I
said I don't I don't respond
to rudeness I I caught the conversation
are you one of them men that don't make
like you won't make your woman get to
you as in if she was to tell you to shut
up and you just walked away you'd go
about your day like everything's fine
wow she's miserable around the house
that's her problem and then you make her
come to you okay I'm not making her do
anything in it if if you're
disrespectful it's not I'm not under
duress to kind of satisfy how you feel
it's her responsibility to come to you
and talk about it no because because
okay but in that scenario women create
and whip themselves up into you know a
frenzy emotionally you know what I mean
and if and a lot of the time if you take
on someone else's emotional baggage it
can affect your day like you said like
if if I take on your emotional baggage
it may affect my day I don't want to do
that so I will go along with my day and
I will be okay and if you if and when
because we all know what happened prior
to it prior to me going on my day if and
when you're ready to address what went
on them we'll address it but I'm not
gonna do me personally because I hear
what you're saying I I'm not going to do
the back and forth like I'm just going
to even like come like say like two
hours and everything's calmed down you
would not address it if you told me to
shut up I must come to you no no like
after
you talk I told you sharp you walked
away we didn't speak for like two hours
then we sat down well I think that's
okay it's like a feminine point of view
though because like we don't let things
go but men do yeah so like we're the
ones that hold on to like those 10
things that happen yeah and so for us
after we get into it argument you're
like you wouldn't say anything yeah
literally that sounds horrible but like
to guys it's just like different
everyone will come out to you about two
hours later and be like so are we not
gonna speak about what just happened
we've been thinking about this for hours
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then when you when you don't restart
the conversation she'll be like oh
that's toxic masculinity I think you
need to be more in touch with your
emotions and communicate more true which
are all those tactics to get you into
another silly conversation right not
necessarily because obviously what are
you because we're men we're not allowed
to communicate
[Music]
you know what it is I think it is I
think men and women communicate
differently 100 that's what it is it's
like women want men to communicate with
them the way they communicate do you get
what I'm saying and so when you like
when you when you've been quiet for
three hours or whatever
and a woman comes to you and says
she wants you to communicate with her
the way she communicates yeah I don't I
me I don't necessarily communicate like
that so you're not first of all you're
not gonna get me to communicate on your
terms you're not gonna manipulate
situation and and secondly if and when
it's time for me to communicate I can
talk to you it's not a problem but like
I said if if you're communicating to
draw me back onto I I've always said
this right women have a battlefield and
men have a battlefield in the way they
communicate for me I always tell them I
never get drawn onto women's Battlefield
when an argument because they argue
differently from us and they will drag
you onto that Battlefield and they will
win because you are not well versed in
the way in which women argue I feel I
feel like women argue with manipulation
they argue with emotion and you know
when all when all else fails they'll
pull the victimhood card yeah do you
know what I'm saying and so it's like if
I get drawn into that they will always
win I I did a video on this I never
really got triggered argue with with
with most most women like obviously that
I have some female friends that are
intelligent and you know they think in a
logical way and so we can have these
kind of discussions but 99 of the time I
don't because most of the time that the
meter engage in discussion with you I
have to believe that you actually want
to reach an end like you actually I have
to yeah there's a good thing I'll argue
for Solutions we want to be heard no she
wants to route you up that's that's why
she's arguing in it so that's why you
know there will be these shame relations
they'll be moving the goal posts because
she's not trying to find the answer
she's just trying to like get a rise out
of you and that's fair enough right
because you know that's my problem is
your problem when you let that get to
you and then you start acting feminine
having this Tit for Tat and you know
moving into that lane because a you're
not going to get anywhere anyway right
those conversations never ending oh I
see your point now actually yeah yeah
that makes sense you know this last two
hours of shouting really really kind of
that never happened two she won't
respect you because you've been acting
like a [ __ ] you're arguing with her Tit
for Tat you look like one of her female
friends right now yeah no one respects
that okay I get what you're saying but
you're only talking about arguing what
about I'm talking about communication
depends conversation about it
conversation where I use a lot have gone
wrong you don't want to improve the
situation by having a conversation okay
no she's not wrong you know she's done
wrong right so she asks you you know
certain questions you're not you're not
going to respond back to it you expect
her to know what kind of conversation
has people telling you to shut up that
sounds a bit like a no I'm not talking
about I'm talking about the solution the
solution you're talking about the
problem you're talking about the
solution
okay well in a in a normal kind of
let's say a conversation we're trying to
get to a solution right
who's interested the solution in for
both parties
I don't see how if if someone's
overstepped boundaries or they've been
read or disrespectful and you now want
us to come to a solution
but you've kind of violated your end of
the agreement in terms of not being
respectful Etc then in my view I don't
really owe you yeah restarting that
conversation because that's your best so
would you ever have a conversation with
a girl about like a disagreement yeah I
State my view she states her view we can
have a a kind of a fruitful discussion
but if there's just respect you know I
kind of just and it's never happened
you're saying if there's disrespect you
walk away you'll have a conversation
later if she initiates it yeah so that's
kind of that's kind of her problem you
know why I understand you know why I
understand because I mean that's bad
communication no but you know why I
understand because women are habitual
landsteppers yeah and a lot of women are
habitual lines and so if they push the
line there they're like next time
and so and so when you when you do not
give them what they want right then
essentially they're going to do it again
no they'll learn because no because no
because you're doing it for a reaction
if you don't get the desired reaction
yeah they will do it you're gonna no no
you're gonna try something different so
hold on so I'm gonna try something
I get it but I can take a shot once I'm
going to take shop again because if you
if I try to shop and you just sharp
because to me you shop even though you
feel like you've just gone quiet and
doing what you're doing that's me
and you know what I would shut up
hang on hang on I would shut up and
you'd never see me again okay and then
he's done no that's my shot because you
try to push the boundaries twice yeah
you wanted me you tried to tell me to
shut up I'll shut up you won't see me
again
and then you're gonna be like cool email
on my phone oh my God babe come back no
you told me to shut up I'm gone no it's
I wonder there's boundaries you just
don't crush
I wouldn't even be that like um it
wouldn't necessarily lead to me kind of
cutting you off I would just kind of
like lose a bit of respect for you and
you'd know because I'll kind of look at
you like
but where's the communication the
communication communication tracking
isn't arguing checking is telling a
woman what it is and if she doesn't like
it then y'all move on if a woman tells
her man to shut up and he puts his head
down and says nothing it looks weak as
[ __ ] Lakers on so it seems like these
guys are just like
when no it's not even necessary talking
is communicating your point your about
yours there's nothing wrong with
communication
hang on I'll just say this the least
amount of communication or understanding
is done during an argument
yeah communication is kind of done via
when things are calmed down you know
what I'm saying that's when
communication we need to have a you know
a respectful kind of stable conversation
but if if we're at a point where she's
saying shut up man or whatever then you
know that's kind of that's funny to me
so I'd look at you as like you know and
then move on and I mean that that's just
how you hold yourself as a man if some
of you guys hear that and you think
that's weak then it's because you're
weak in it because your silence is
weaker my silence is strong I don't have
to talk I don't have to you know do this
tip for that thing you know we don't
have to have this conversation you know
I I do I get where you're coming from
but I kind of feel like as times are
moving on you have to evolve as a person
or as a man it's not it's not we
shouldn't be just stereotyped to one way
of doing things
it's a course of behavior it's a course
of behavior well I'm going to be honest
with you right
I'm a 34 year old man I've been in my
fair share of relationships and I've
seen different things from different
people and like you can't always have
the same message yes you can have your
the doctrine of keeping quiet when the
disrespect is there but there are some
people who actually don't get it so true
I've practiced I've practiced question
method practice your method sorry to
finish I've practiced your method and
sometimes that doesn't always work
question why are you dealing with
disrespectful women then because because
sometimes you don't know the disrespect
or maybe it's a case of unto you know
better you do better right this this
never happens to me this this
conversation like when men talk about
like please when you write your book I
will definitely I'm writing a book
actually online
masculine is my YouTube channel but um
essentially this idea of like you know
some women are just again it's kind of
framing it like you're in a passive seat
listen you're here because I allow you
to be here right no woman can walk into
my house you can't slide into my DMs and
be present without my me deciding you
can be so this this idea that without
engaging in that yeah like this this
idea that like disrespect is some kind
of fact of the universe is no when
you're around me you're on borrow time
you know that so don't ever speak to me
without being cautious of what you say
that's just how I do things sorry 50
Super Chat The Men Who know now say less
have that look that says are you nuts
and learn to never tolerate disrespect
walk away people are 50.
I tell you what I think it's like I
think it's like for those that did grow
up with their fathers right there was a
there was a look your father could give
you
and he didn't have to say anything do
you know what I mean like he didn't have
to say a damn thing like he looked like
that look of are you absolutely crit and
you black but that how many times do you
have to do that look
no but the thing is I'm not saying how
many times but in a relationship yeah
but the thing is you know it might sound
controversial but sometimes women are
kind of like children do you know what
I'm saying so humans like children
sometimes yeah yeah but women women
they respond what was happening Kinda
Yeah Yeah women respond to that
masculine energies everyone does like
yeah it's everyone this this is exactly
what you do in a situation with a male
pair in the office Etc I'm really just
telling you guys comments Common Sense
stuff like if if if you're out here
dating women that are disrespectful
taking it to Sharp and that's your
reality and and you're out here I think
this is what you showed them telling me
coping mechanisms to do with that then
that's on you but that never happens to
me because I don't date rude women I
don't tolerate rudeness
what were you saying what were you
saying you said you answered no I'm
thinking about like
men tend to I feel like you don't tend
to do
facial expressions and all of these
things with your
like you don't tend to do that and
expect us to understand not every woman
understand I get it but not everyone
will understand it do you know why you
do understand it I don't like you
because no because you know when you're
being disrespectful not even that no no
and you know and you know when you're
pushing the boundary I'm thinking of it
like you know back in the day I don't
know well when I was younger like my dad
would say like he wouldn't even say
nothing if there's something on the
floor he'll just look at it expect me to
pick it up you can communicate with your
mouth say pick up that thing I mean like
well you knew he was yeah
so you heard it and the fact that you
heard it means that you wanted them to
repeat himself and say explicitly
verbally because that was a power play
for you right it was a power player
because you wanted to say can I make you
have to tell me what to do before I do
it even though I know full well what
you're saying it's about well
communicating with facial expressions no
but the thing is did you know not to did
you whatever it is that I was on the
floor did you walk past it a couple of
times knowing that you should have
picked it up right yes exactly so you
already know that's why I said okay
people already know what they should and
should not do they try to do things for
attention right bro clock how clock how
she didn't what I told you women do is
like you came out and tried to pretend
you didn't and tried to say you should
just communicate better boys this is how
it works this is the game she she just
told you that she already knew but she
came out and said you could have just
used words why do you want me she would
not have respected them if you would
have been like can you pick that up
exactly she's a woman so she would
prefer to say look could you pick that
up as opposed to just going I don't care
what you prefer this isn't this is like
that I don't care what you prefer like
that's the way it works
and that's a man response exactly so you
have to understand if you're dealing
with if a deal with a man right and you
know your men men communicate in a
certain way I communicate in a certain
way so if I already know that you know
why do you now want me to acknowledge
that I know that you know by verbalizing
what you listening
why are you still doing it no I don't I
don't give in to that kind of minute
because that's manipulation but all he's
saying is yeah that's manipulation oh
sorry I forgot your name but all all
you're saying is I would preferred for
someone to have told me but that's her
preference she would rather words than
looks that's the way I don't owe you
compliance with what you feel and what
you prefer again
then you should and if you understand
that that's what I expected if you're
looking at me like a piece of [ __ ]
imagine imagine if you went into life
thinking like this imagine if I went
into the office
expected people to tell me things let me
let me give you a scenario this is my
phone right and I put my phone down and
you know you're not supposed to steal my
phone right and you pick my phone up and
I'm just gonna
foreign
you already know you already know you
weren't supposed to already know but why
but why do you need why'd you need me to
tell you hey that's my phone don't pick
it up because because we're women and
we're addicted to attention right yes
and that's why they hate it when you
you're silent and you walk away yeah
because if you take away I genuinely
believe if you take away attention from
from women that is the number the
control room and it's happened to me
before too I'm not special but I think
it could also be I'm not a specialist um
okay I'm have a question that I was
gonna ask
um
do you think men are the biggest threat
to women or the biggest Protectors of
women
I would say protectors because a woman
is not going to protect me no offense
but you're you're 20. if we was to have
this conversation was he 20 sorry if he
was to have this conversation I'm not
saying your experiences are irrelevant
I'm not I'm just saying I know at 20 I
had a completely different mindset to
you and once and this is one men the
younger women because they're a little
bit more naive sometimes
easier to manipulate they don't really
have to deal with they like kids
there's enough I've seen a lot of things
though that generational trauma no
that's the truth why would a guy want a
traumatized wife right why would he pick
that why would a woman want an abuser
why is your immediate reaction because
why are you throwing that out there like
no one wants to talk about no no one
wants a traumatized person I'm not
saying that man should the man should
sell for that at all but a man's God
step back and realize that he's part of
the problem okay why would a man who has
never abused you be part of the problem
um why I'm part of the problem you're
American you're a white woman you're
part of the problem how are you going to
sit there yeah
no no I want you to stand on that what
what problem am I a part of
you think that being Wyatt and a woman
has benefited your life
do I think being white and a woman has
has it gone in your favor being a white
woman because I know statistically if I
was to go missing tonight on the way
home and and you did they're going to be
looking for me more than you I know that
that's not fair but that is the way he
is right and and that that's what
baffles me is when we could talk about
race we can see it like that but like
when we can like I said to you earlier
like I'm English I know full well if I'm
out and people are slower in the English
I ain't got nothing to say what can I
say it's true but but you're you're
making the assumption that that men are
slaughtering women and that's just not
the case and even if you're gonna you're
gonna talk about me what did I do
what do you mean
because you're saying you're part of the
problem but how how what we are we are
because like who's who's who's who's
gonna be the ones to end racism black
people or white people it would be like
me sitting there saying to you you tell
your sons okay okay but but otherwise
they ain't gonna get they ain't gonna
get emotionally abused you tell you it's
on your end that's what it's like saying
but if I if I'm not racist how am I part
of the problem because you've benefited
no I understand what you're saying and I
agree like that's what like if anything
like I I have a whole team in Nigeria
that works for me yeah and literally
I've changed their lives like they live
like kings but why did you change their
lives is it not because of colonization
how is it it's not colonization was it
Nigeria it was because it was because I
trained them on how to cut clips and
make thoughts I understand what you're
saying I helped them get a skill that
can make them a lot of money but even
the way you said it like I made their
life bearers it was a bit like white
complex no it's not white complex
we're talking about race we're talking
about racism okay so the problem
I'm not racist how am I a part of the
problem because I would imagine that
some pay at some point you've enabled
some sort of racism why are you asking
that assumption because I am
racist towards me
have you enabled recently I think I've
been in situations where I've heard
someone or something been said and I
haven't addressed it like I should okay
I'll admit that because to me they're a
bit thick right they are thick not a bit
so I know I'm arguing stupid do you see
what I mean that's their opinion but I
appreciate that is the problem because I
should be more vocal and say oh yeah
what the [ __ ] you talking about instead
of just ignoring it
I'm saying if you did that that's a you
problem why are you projecting because I
think I think if you're white and you're
saying that you've never done I think
you're a bit of a liar if that I've
never done what I think if you've been
in a situation where you've seen racism
or you've heard something and you
haven't pulled someone up on it I think
you're like if I saw something racist I
would say something but that's the thing
I think at some point in your life you
probably haven't and that's what I'm
trying to say why are you making that
assumption when you don't know me why
are you making certain assumptions about
me when you think I haven't made any
assumptions
I said older women are traumatized more
traumatized yeah 100 in general I never
said anything about you oh oh because I
thought earlier there was like a common
thing about this sounds like trauma if
if I said that it sounds like trauma it
was based off of things you said I
wouldn't make it I wouldn't make I
wouldn't make an assumption about you
that was not based off of things you
said yeah should I tell you what's hard
to listen to though is that is that you
will say that about that the trauma or
whatnot but if I say to you I I don't
think women are safe walking home late
at night or whatnot one first of all
you're quick to put it on me and I
should move and I should do this and I
should do that but at the same time
you're not really addressing where I'm
coming from because you're quickly
saying you're traumatized
I'm saying based on the words that come
out of your mouth you blame men for
things yeah and I say why don't you take
accountability and if you are feel
unsafe walking home alone why don't you
live somewhere else I think that's
because I I believe in taking personal
accountability for where your life is
and for me
um I I don't you you see where I'm at I
don't live in the best area but I made
sure I lived in a place with security so
I could feel safe but you kind of you
probably have more choices than me I I
don't know but I I don't understand but
I'm saying I'm saying I can imagine that
there's a lot of places to live in in
England and you there was not one
apartment that you were you had a gun to
your head and they said you must live
here but that's what happens with the
council you you bid what what
so that means you you've been working
since 18. you could have chosen to get
married you could have never wanted to
get married okay okay but it's a choice
that's the whole point of course that is
because it's not that you're punished
but you're making other people pay for
your bad decisions the government and
people pay taxes into the government if
it's the same way it's in the US I don't
completely understand Section 8 but if
it's government assisted housing that is
you not being financially responsible
and you put yourself in that situation
but this is what I'm kind of saying I
didn't want to say this to you because I
knew you would say this and it weren't
because I was avoiding responsibility we
can have a talk after and talk about my
situation that's fine but the problem is
you are directing it more at me than
anything else
with what's going on is that you're
based in your scenario like just I don't
know what's happened in your life
and I respect it but
um my joy I don't know just by the
little I'm not saying little but that
probably was like I don't know how many
men you probably being abused or you
know by but you're judging that no no
but this is what I tried to say earlier
I'm not stupid so if I was the only
person I've never known to have been
followed home or touched I wouldn't have
these opinions
there are so many men in the world there
is but you've also got men that are
raping kidding and raping and killing
and not getting the repercussions yeah
but the thing is why why hang on this is
the thing why is it that you keep
hanging on yeah the trauma and the
negativity
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait when men have shown themselves
like we said earlier in this situation
in the show to build the world in which
you live men have built the world in
which you live they've built this how
they probably built this this apartment
you probably got here on the public
transport they built that men have
literally built the world in which you
live in and you think it's okay to just
sit there and be speaking I feel like
men are bad men are [ __ ] more than you
that probably won't have the same
thought process as you do you know who
sorry says there's definitely woman in
the world that's gone through more than
what you've gone through that won't
happen of course but there's women that
I volunteer at a nature reserve in um
East ham and I'm dealing with uh the
majority of the volunteers are over 70.
what would you teach your child or your
card your little siblings or in what
sort of about men because I've got a son
[Music]
um I know because I'm teaching him how
to treat women I'm not letting it be
Society telling I'm not not letting it
be a toxic man
when you're listening to songs talking
about raping women raping when you're
watching films where you're watching
audience oh have you not I think I could
show you guys I think I think it's what
I think is interesting here is how like
you you use very minute kind of um
anomaly pack like situations that are
far out of Norm to justify very extreme
beliefs I don't think so I think I could
say whatever I wanted and you would
never agree because that's one thing I
know you you seem to avoid
accountability at every level
okay for example you say if Paul says so
for example your housing this Alleyway
thing you're talking about right and if
anyone says maybe you could move
somewhere else you could do it this way
I did you seem to always look for a
reason to not have control agency over
these situations
why is it victim blaming to say where
you're at in life is your own fault it's
based off the choices your mate at 18
one thing but your 32 you're a grown
woman yeah you've had over a decade to
make double choices yeah and if you're
on government housing and you've made
poor decisions to get there like that's
all you know you know you can't pay you
know it's not all subsidized you do know
that don't you so I I told you I didn't
understand so so you're you're kind of
almost going with like a narrative that
is all paid for what you you don't know
that you do people that make good
financial decisions end up on this
government housing typically it all
depends their life you don't you don't
of course but there's going to be the
answer is no you can't do if you're
trying to scam the system okay so
typical I'm just asking okay just in the
room are you guys are from here
typically no
do people that are on the housing that
she described typically make good
financial decisions no you have people
in new development government housing
and they're trying to ladder up and buy
the housing but no they don't it's not
really let's just be honest no they
probably made some poor choices to get I
should tell you what it was I moved out
young that was why and it kind of set me
back a little bit because I I moved out
young so you're facing and this is where
it's this is where I get annoyed because
you've had over a decade no no no you're
you're again this is the thing because
I'm from what you've said if I was to go
home tonight get a bus go down an
Alleyway and get brutally great your
answer would be well you should have
done something to not put yourself in
the alleyway
is what you basically said I don't know
I would say press charges but but they
never get done that's not necessarily
true it is I mean let's let's there are
many situations where women have falsely
recruit used men of things and they have
gone to jail for it
that's the narrative to say to take away
for the fact of how many people are
great and how many people people don't
go to prison for it it's easy to say oh
yeah
okay okay I'll give you an example there
is a guy in the U.S he was in college
and a girl said that he raped her or
that she that he raped her right and
then they released security footage of
her pulling him back to the dorm kissing
him
um he was pulling away from her she
still kissed him pulling him back to her
dorm and he still got kicked out of
college because that's terrible yeah I'm
saying to you that's terrible I'm not
saying he deserves that it's about
that's what I'm saying and I'm saying
what I would say is there are situations
as a woman you should try not to put
yourself
you you have yeah and I'm saying sorry
like
there I'm not okay you have a son
there's women out here that actually lie
yeah yeah say one day a woman says
you're gonna believe the woman over your
son I would find that one hard it all
depends on the sort of man no no no but
listen it all depends on the sort of man
that I raised do you see what I mean I
might feel like I can raise that man
with that man but you don't know him
outside Gucci I answer that you ask you
a question though say if I said to you
now someone graved me would you and it
turns out I'm a liar right I've lied
about it all wouldn't you though you're
not as much as lying about it is
terrible oh [ __ ] as much as lying about
it is terrible isn't being the greatest
worse yeah there we are then yeah
I don't understand that actually hold on
so she lies but it's it's worse that she
could have been telling them no no no no
no no no no no not at all you're
twisting it to make it seem to me like
if if a man is falsely accused of rape
okay great sorry sorry sorry the chances
are he's more likely to have done it
than not and that's statistically bad
wow more likely to be graved by another
man than you are falsely accused no no
no no you're talking about you're
talking about you're talking about hang
on you're talking about the accusation
you're saying if a man is accused of it
yeah yeah he's more likely to have
statistically backed hang on hang on if
you could Google it I don't know I'm
asking like you're a Messengers
I don't think I I just I just think if a
woman come to me and said look I've been
graped by this person I would rather
believe her and find out she's a liar
then then turn turn my back on her and
believe a great picture that's one there
we are that's one
I would disagree
but this is all situational because I
have to turn around to even say wow that
ain't never gonna happen like I don't
know why you're trying why would I just
believe someone I don't know that that's
stupid
I was gonna believe someone because it's
worse but you would believe they're not
a great piece you don't know that I I
wouldn't believe anybody until the facts
come out and and so you're you made the
claim that the majority of women that
come forward they're telling the truth
right oh yeah I would say okay but if
that was true then why aren't the don't
the majority of girls that press charged
just why don't they why don't they go to
jail
if the evidence there is there they go
to jail what the woman if she's full C
accused Goes to Jail no no I'm saying
I'm saying the majority of girls that
press charges it doesn't get taken to
the to court they don't go to jail okay
and so and so I'm saying why
I think I think you're maybe missing a
point in how much like no no no trying
to understand the claim yeah no no this
is what I'm trying to explain that that
how much the system is set up to not
listen to women I know women
me too is like one of the biggest memes
I'm trying to tell you I'm trying to
tell you stuff to back my claims but
yeah I apologize I've known a woman to
be abused by her police officer's
husband to go to call with evidence and
it to be thrown out I've known women to
have been great who have had to drive
nearly five hours down the road to the
country to to be set down by a policeman
and tell her that they ain't interested
in it I've seen it all right so I I
understand again because I'm traumatized
I'm not worth listening to but at the
same time I can't understand no no I
can't understand that I've got all of
this to say to you and there's still a
kind uh the only man I've known to be
falsely accused the rape I knew rape
someone great sorry sorry so I know I
it's not that it's not that we're not we
don't respect what you're saying
anecdotal evidence when it's not backed
by data
no what I'm saying is backed by data
because you can look at the numbers you
can look at you can look up the number
of women that report a crime and you can
look up how many men were actually press
charges and it is not the majority so
I'm saying like you're just going based
off of word I'm going off of Base I'm
going based off of evidence but that
sometimes that doesn't it's not looking
at them you don't know as a woman what
it's like to be accused
and so as a man yeah we understand that
that type of accusation yeah could
destroy our whole life 100 yeah if if if
it is false it can destroy our whole
life
hang on no but hang on but hang on as a
man
as men hear if we get falsely accused of
that right it doesn't at this time it
doesn't even matter whether we've done
it or not well the only thing the only
thing that matters is that people
believe it yeah yeah right in these days
and times so when we are asking for
evidence of it yeah and you say oh well
the majority of women that say it it's
happened to them which as a man I'm
thinking but it hasn't been proven and
as a man I'm gonna require some kind of
proof to show that this thing has
happened because if I get falsely
accused I know that my life's finished
everyone every man here knows if they
get falsely accused their life is
finished so wouldn't it just be more
fair
for there to be evidence to back up your
claim
but the thing is I don't even think is
out there on the internet I I got phone
I haven't got the numbers on my head I
said that I'm sorry I I don't even know
what do you want me to look up if you
talk if you talk about grape statistics
and and false allegations okay okay
false allegations is there a stat that I
can look at I think it was I think it
was the great crisis
um can I I can't use my phone because
can I just can't you can you can use it
for this sentence
can I just say that on this show before
we spoke of a book called how to destroy
a man right there's a book on Amazon
that you can buy called how to destroy a
man
on Amazon right now and it's a handbook
for women yeah put it actually you can
Google it right now it's called how to
destroy a man it's a handbook as to how
women can leverage allegations and for
and for and accusations right against
men right and that was it was actually
published in 2018. so for publicly or
it's on Amazon
so if a book like that can be published
as to how to destroy a man who as men
think of us as men we don't know
I think there's a first of all there's a
Marketplace second of all we don't know
who's read it can I can I just can I
just say something that I would never
agree with that as much as we don't
agree I'm not going to sit here as a
woman and say yeah oh yeah that's fine
that's fine that's fine but I will say
like when you're making that when you're
saying about that and that's really
outrageous to you do you not find
outrageous that there's categories on
porn websites
of girls being great there's there's
Reddit there's a website when when you
was talking
um about Netflix about oh not Netflix
sorry about that man in America who who
lost all of everything there's there's
um a documentary on Netflix called Aubry
and Daisy about two girls in an American
High School that both got graped they
both ended up killing themselves they
both got kicked out of school because
the men that done the boys had done it
to them were were seen as the
Untouchable because their parents had
links
you keep bringing up these super sad
situations and I agree we don't like
rapists and I agree that false
allocations are terrible but I think one
outweighs the other no no the difference
this is what feminists do they're always
competing with that's the floor it's
always a competition like I'm saying I'm
saying it's not it's not a competition
I'm not saying it's a competition but
I'm saying Miss Andre is a is a
consequence of all it is no no it's not
a consequence
no accountability if you're justifying
your your poor Behavior no that's why by
blaming it on a very small groups
things that come out of your mouth are
very misandristic yes
like all men are men
it's when you're talking about men in a
general way like we should be afraid of
them it's is that what you're saying I I
think if I had a daughter I would be
bringing her up to be conscious and of
being but this is the thing again I'm
coming from a situation where I've got a
son who's no no
I would love you to meet my boy because
my boy is is incredible he really is
like I said I've got women at a school
Gates
come on I've got women at the school
Gates who are old enough to be my mum
who are married telling me my son's a
good kid I wish my boy was like yours I
like the fact that my boy plays videos
my boy I've brought him up not to enable
stuff I said to him you are who your
friends are so when all of his mates
want to go around playing knocked down
Ginger and Nick and things from the
neighbors he comes in he's going to a
very very good school he's a good kid so
the fact that you're looking at me and
thinking oh she can't raise a boy but
when In fairness I have raised a really
good there's lots of good boys out there
we don't know your son no but when
what I'm saying is I think it's really
sad to raise a kid with your view on men
I think that is that's fine
and then tell me how much why is his
father not influencing him as well I I
don't want to get into that that's my
son's personal life I'm not going to
talk about that um I I think what's
what's most worrying for me is you you
justify these extreme viewpoints would
you consider yourself as being kind of
um indoctrinated no I should tell you
what like I said you have an objective
Viewpoint no no no no so I just I just
think I I can't I'm I'm more a little
bit confused as to how I'm sitting in
the room with two women who it's not
that I think every woman should think
that is I just can't this is why I said
to you like I think Miss is it Miss
Andrew is how you pronounce it I think
it's a knock-on effect I'm misogyny and
I'll stick to that that's my views
the thing is I don't think that I
thought you believed women yeah I don't
it's not but are you who are you
accusing the grape do you know what it
is
I'm saying when I say my experience in
the world you don't seem to think it's
reality no I do it's just different
times because it's just different I
don't know I'll give I'll give you an
example like when she was talking you
would say oh it's just because you're
young but instead of you know believing
women like I thought feminists do you
you discount her experience because
she's young I should tell you what but
this is the thing if I'm gonna listen to
any advice I'm gonna listen to someone
older so when I was saying about the
Nature Reserve I'm listening to women
who are 74. well educated married
married and the ones that aren't are
[ __ ] happy as Larry they've got their
they've got their friends they do their
clubs and all of this so the thing is
I'm listening to women and they haven't
got kids that the one that I'm talking
to has hasn't got kids but at the same
time I'm talking to a 74 year old who
was about when women were allowed to be
having contraception and she told me
that that when she went to UNI you would
have to take a marriage to to the doctor
to get contraception which is weird
actually contraception yeah I think we
should too yeah well I think we should
ban it it has weird effects yeah oh 100
it's got weird effects on women but then
you're going to have a lot of unwanted
pregnancies no or you could just you
know make better sexual decisions you
know or just accept there were animals
and we like to enjoy ourselves
here you are trying to make it out
though I've just outing myself as some
slack I'm saying we're animals women
have urges just as men yeah but we're
human we can control them of course this
is why I say to men but you say about
men that that if a man behind his wife's
back in one handshake most men do
control their urges one one out of three
Mana virgins are having had sex in the
past year if we're going to talk about
cheating I don't condone cheating but I
think it's different for men and for
women 100 no 100 it's a different topics
yeah yeah no 100 but again it sometimes
boils down to being an animal I don't I
don't I don't think that's that's that's
not what I said I
said this is coming this is coming from
a man that said and then can't be
victims of women
what you're saying is men with a certain
mindset have a hard time being victims
he did not say that men can't be victims
well he did obviously next to him he
said
you said that you feel like you said
that you'll sit in the room too of a
woman that you feel like should have
yeah yeah not like my view but the thing
is sorry I just feel like you're very
like
you're like narrow-minded about
everything no at all you don't you don't
know me I don't know
but we're talking about this as a
discussion so you see him in everyday
life I'm completely different but we're
here to talk about this so of course I'm
gonna have a sister called basically you
feel you feel like the sister code was
broken
that's basically what you feel like no
no you're just saying I can't believe
I'm in here with two women that uh that
you know that wouldn't because what it
is I said a lot of the time women
believe that because you're another
woman you're supposed to see it just the
way I see it whereas whereas whereas us
as men you saw I don't know why you saw
these all of us can disagree we don't
necessarily think that you're not
believing us you're saying you're blind
to us I understand but at the same time
that I was looking into this
I feel like you're blind to it by this
yeah that's fine but that's our opinions
I've never met her in my life never no
we have the same opinion and so did you
react to a story is that how you're here
is that is did she was yeah I said yeah
well there you are so that would make
sense why why you agree with her and and
I don't agree with both of you really
because I have a lot of people on me
look at my comment section there's a lot
of people that disagree yeah but but
that's the thing that's what I'm saying
that you don't know me I'm not someone
to be online but my online argument my
point my point okay okay but my point is
we're two different women and every time
we talk about our beliefs on things you
discount it the feminist who who seems
to think we should believe women but
every time you say every time we say we
believe something you give an excuse I
just disagree with you no no you you say
oh it's because you're young oh it's
because you're white oh it's because
that like like you give an excuse for
why we believe it instead of just but
the thing is we're just different I said
to you earlier though I've seen some of
the videos that and when you spoke about
her certain things the first thing is
fat fat fat people people are different
I am completely aware that maybe the
first thing I do I do 16 hours of shows
a week and the first thing I say in
every show is fat no I'm talking about
when you're talking about women you like
do you like to describe them you like to
to talk about that and and whatnot but
but what I'm saying to you I I can
appreciate that you have got a different
opinion to me I knew I was coming on
here I know I weren't going to agree
with you I knew that okay I'm probably
sure that's why he said come on here
because he knew this yeah but at the
same time I I can accept that my my
circumstances my my life has gone in a
completely different direction and we
will never agree so into a sentence I'm
not saying I'm not saying that what
you're saying is [ __ ] I'm not saying
that you are who you are because you're
young I'll just be interested to see how
you would feel about certain things
I know I'm young but I feel like
as young as I may be I could have I
could be free so much yeah yeah I mean
and that's the thing you don't know my
story yeah that's what I'm trying to say
is as much as I've been through so much
I don't have the same of course but if
I'm gonna listen to the 20 year old or
I'm gonna listen to the 74 year old
that's had a life of experience a 74
year old somebody listen to you see
that's what I'm saying to you like no no
I talk to a lot of people you you don't
really you don't know I talk to her a
lot I would say I would argue I talk to
more people
I I would agree I would agree okay I
think for me it's your inability to
understand that your your experiences or
the things you because in my experience
people like you tend to chase certain
narratives because it's like what you
want to hear you want to read something
you want to reaffirm the idea that
everyone is experiencing these kinds of
um these these confirmation bias when
you look at when you look at the data
and it says oh 100 people experience uh
you know that essay in in London and you
realize that like 150 000 people died
from cancer and almost 400 000 people
died from everything else you discount
all that all those other causes of
mortality all those issues and say oh
but a hundred people died in one year
and that's a sign that you believe this
because it's a massive issue
100.
this is what makes me laugh about these
sort of discussions
what do you think every man's like we're
just talking about
using the right smaller numbers the
right words sometimes sometimes they're
using rare occasions to justify once
again
can I can I just read something so I'm
just going off of the great thing this
is a U.S stat I will say not UK
um from 1995 to 2010 the estimated
annual array of female grape or sa
victimization declined from declined 58
from five victimizations per a thousand
females
to 2.1 per thousand
so it's not but isn't it let's report
how do you know yeah I see that I'll
find that what do you mean
let's just take that premise okay like
so that that's that's your argument that
there's more grape and it's not reported
how would you know how would you know it
doesn't happen assume every man is a
predator
so don't flip the question so I know
people I know numerous people they've
been raped and haven't so much
let me let me just get this straight so
you're going off of Word of Mouth no
personal experience who I know so so
okay okay people you know yeah how did
you know were you there
it sounds like this this is a sort of
woman diet no offense to you that you
look at me and think [ __ ] that I look at
you and think [ __ ] that like I don't
know the question
answer the question no no I wasn't there
sorry I wasn't there I wasn't there so
it's based off of what what they've
based off of what they said correct
so your that means you're discounting
anyone and this is convictions
answer my question is it was I there are
you are you basing this opinion off of
what women say
um it's it's more sort of how I see no
not emotion how I see the situation if I
know someone
uh say if I know someone had never had
sex before in their life and wasn't that
way inclined and then got great I would
believe them because from what I've seen
from them they're not like that okay but
it's based off of what women say but but
how would you not believe it yeah of
course of course but who would would you
in that situation would you not what
what is okay you keep flipping them no
I'm asking you whatever I'm saying
exactly
yes
so so I'm just I'm just clarifying so so
your assertion that that it's
underreported is based off of believing
women without evidence 100 okay that's
that's my only point so so then so then
so if we follow the logic what can we do
in society
or how do you think society would run if
we believed everybody about wait just
wait if we believed everybody
based on what they said without any
evidence well I I think that's bollocks
but we're not talking about that we're
not talking about everything that'd be
like you saying oh that sound bloke was
racist to me that I mean I prove it yes
that's exactly what it is that this is
the theme because are you now just
supposed to I feel like this because are
you just supposed to take what I say
happened or should there be evidence to
also back it up I I completely
understand what you're saying and I
agree I agree it would be a dangerous
world if we could if we could just
believe everything do you see what I
mean please please but please but you're
not you're not getting it but I'm
looking at a bigger picture so I say if
you said to me
um oh someone's racist or whatnot I I
can appreciate we live in a slightly
racist country so I would kind of uh use
my brain and think you know what because
at the end of the day there's not
evidence for everything so you you're
you're kind of as much as as you're like
kind of saying to me I believe in
everyone
um
it's a bit dangerous as well the flip
side to to only credit people with
evidence because evidence there's
there's you can you can watch stuff like
this and you can see whether it's murder
or what and it will be discounting that
evidence
tell you what did you know what happened
to me today go on so Bigfoot
yeah but come on now I saw a big
difference believe me
no I've got no evidence I've got no
evidence whatsoever just believe me no
no I always bollocks now because that's
a you're saying to me no way about these
random little things to brew my pain
what you just said is absolutely
not saying this but just saying I could
go to someone and say he was racist too
yeah of course you could and because
you're white yeah someone should believe
me no I'm not I'm not saved by this
again this is where it gets twisted I'm
saying from my own personal view I know
people no no but I know that people have
been great and they haven't reported it
so when it comes to Great statistics in
the same way like we talk about men's
problems and whatnot that now suicide we
know is is higher but women women commit
more they tried to commit more and they
report it more so if men reported it
more maybe it would be a case of women
trying more do you see what I mean but
unless you're if you're not reporting
things but at the same time you can view
male suicide as extremely sad you're
like you're moving the goal post because
you're not listening to a word I'm sorry
she made a point
it's no it's not because every time
every time someone brings up a point
I'm saying I could literally come out
here today and say of course you're like
you could I could literally cry to
someone say you was racist but the thing
is if someone if someone believes I know
believe her don't believe her because
you're white but that's fine I will
stand there and I know I've got people
that know me that will back me and say
that that happened fair enough they
weren't there a man could say that I
could say you know what I believe that
he's not yeah of course I know her she's
not I know I know the truth she's not
alone I've known her for 10 years but
she knows she's Liars but she knows
she's lied about it
no but this but then but again you're
kind of not because I'm saying this is
where those sort of viewpoints come from
Injustice no no but do you understand we
understand how bad it is and that's why
men can just be pinpoint as they've done
how many meant that this is the thing
there's people on telly that have been
accused of rape or grape there's been
there's been people on telly that have
been accused of it there's been there's
been footballers and this whole
rhetorical oh you're doing it again no
because this whole rhetoric of it ruins
men's lives it's hard to believe when
you're seeing men go off living living
Prof like profitable lives after that's
happened to them where they were were
they were they prosecuted or were they
accused they were accused but this is
what I'm saying okay but see there there
you go again if you've never got the
evidence because it's my word against
stairs okay but yeah this is just this
is just this is just what we're going
back to you just believe women without
evidence and that's and I and these are
I would rather believe a woman and then
and then listen listen and in this case
in this case you don't even know them
yeah yeah so you can't even make the
argument the case you just made where
you said there are footballers that have
that have gotten away with it you're
believing women you don't even know and
you'll believe in a man not to be a
rapist
no no no stop putting words into my
mouth that I did not
saying
I I said to believe the evidence so to
wait until the evidence comes out and if
and if there's no evidence then I would
decide on the fact that it probably
didn't happen or there was not enough
evidence to prosecute I don't know
before there was not enough evidence to
prosecute but I don't know I was not
there why would I make an assumption on
something that I was not there for that
that's fine not you but this is what I'm
saying that it's it's not a thing like
if if you want to believe that that's
that's fine I I personally don't believe
that and I understand when it comes to
this there's such a fine line because
how are you getting that evidence bear
in mind there was uh like there was a
thing up until because that no can I
just say something that if I was if I
was brutally graped and you studied and
I went to the police and then you
started digging into my sexual history
and found out that I liked being I liked
rough sex that goes against me but yet
that was consensual so even that that
that rule has only changed recently that
would make sense but no it doesn't of
course it doesn't yeah if someone has an
Evidence of certain Behavior patterns
yeah so I see but again like this is
what I'm saying we just we just believe
different things and that's fine and and
why why would you want them to be able
to prosecute someone without evidence
because certain things never have any
evidence okay so that's really so so you
think they should process
I see what you're saying but if it meant
like how are you gonna how are you gonna
tell me now then if I if a man doesn't
inside me or there's no DNA or say there
is DNA but there's no much tell me what
evidence you would need to believe it
typically if you you're fighting yeah if
you're getting in grapes so typically I
would imagine there's Cuts there's
there's there's like like bruises that
sort of thing but do you know why do I
not I I don't because I'm not there and
I don't make assumptions based off of
gender I don't I don't believe people
can I use an analogy right well because
you're saying basically you believe
we're women right
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait that's what you said
you're basically are saying be a
believer woman right and as a and I tell
you what that's scary for me as a as a
black male yeah yeah no hang on I'm just
gonna say I'm scared for me as a black
male because I don't know if you know
the case of Emmett Till yeah of course
right okay where a woman said that he
yep he's sexy assaulted after something
for you right and they were living at a
time sorry essayed
um to some degree or even wolf whistled
or whatever it was right and because she
was a woman and like you say oh she was
a white woman yeah yeah she was believed
yeah right and that boy I know Bruce Lee
because of her yeah now you're telling
me right generally believe all women as
if women can't lie so like I've said I'm
looking at it the standpoint you're
looking at it from is a woman's
standpoint I'm looking at it from a
man's standpoint yeah like I said if men
get accused of something yeah it can
ruin our whole life and this is why
Pearl is talking about it has to be
evidenced based it does it's not saying
that you that it never happened that's
not no one's saying that it never
happened I think that's I think I think
no but listen but listen No but listen
no one's saying it never happened we're
saying if it did happen there has to be
some kind of proof that it actually did
happen and if it didn't
these cases where there is evidence and
it still gets discounted I this is what
I'm saying this is what I'm drawing back
to no no no it's not but then I I'll go
back to what I said to you the bottom
line is I would rather believe a liar
than the rapist and and then that's it
that's it I rather believe it alone I
I'm not a Believer like I would rather
wake up one morning and find out the
person I believe that
is is capable of that as opposed to a
man capable of right I think that's easy
to say when you're not the one in their
[ __ ] yeah I can imagine so so this women
will assassinate a man's character and
spread lies about him because women can
be spiteful a hundred percent so and so
I personally I'm not just gonna give
women that power to destroy a man's
character reputation right job
opportunities College opportunities just
because a woman is a woman that's stupid
yeah she felt a certain way but at the
same time it makes me sad to think of
all um the the women out there that
didn't have the evidence that didn't
they got for an alcohol that we can look
at statistics in in sort of that cool
and how much it goes against them yeah
of course but that's but it's not no but
then I don't know
do you do you think it's better to be
innocent until proven guilty or guilty
till proven innocent it is that's a
tough one because I think I think money
and power pick one has no that's what
I'm saying I can't yeah you can't have a
perfect world pick one no no no I I I
don't know how to answer that because
what's fairer what's fairer what's
what's more fair well of course the the
fairer were of the two is um we're with
with evidence of course that no no don't
you mean innocent until proven guilt
yeah that's what I'm saying that's the
third but this is why I don't want to
answer this question because even though
I can see it so do you want to live in a
fair Society or on other side your chain
oh [ __ ] you're you're doing this again
when you're kind of like throwing
questions at me you're not really
listening to kind of what I was trying
to get out right we've been listening no
no but I'm saying I'm not I would I
don't want to pick one or two because I
don't agree with either because I feel
disprove your point no no it's because
if you've got money and you've got power
you can get up with everything you ever
need to be right if you've got money and
you've got a power if you've got money
and power you can get away with
everything if you have money and power
you get away with everything a lot
there's like there's this there's a chef
that's got a restaurant in in London and
Parks outside there every day even
though there's no parking Zone and he
just gets a ticket every day because he
can get away with it because he's got
money
okay I think there's a difference
between tickets
then why is R Kelly in jail how long did
that take was in school when that sex
tape came out with him graping with him
doing whatever he'd done to that okay
okay but that's what happened at the end
how long did it take what happened
how many how many women I don't know how
many women
what happened at the end of the day how
long did he go to jail how long did he
go to jail
you know he went to jail we all know
that but how long did that take how many
that video that video I went to call and
it got it got thrown out okay okay is he
in jail now
yes how many women did he hurt after
that first because because it's innocent
until proven guilty he had the video
because
it's innocent did anyone know that I I
don't I don't I don't know I'm telling
you say no I'm telling you they know but
I'm saying at the end of the day is he
not in jail because if if you said he
could your your claim your claim was
that he could get that people with money
and power can get Harvey Weinstein Jeff
Epstein okay where are they now how long
did it take sometimes just why do you
keep answering questions what's the
point whether it's relevant or not that
they got they got done
how often how often do people go
discredible you watch those documents
you have a need to be right you watch
those documentaries there was countless
women not believe because there weren't
any yeah to be right on every single
thing because I'm here to discuss
something unfortunately I don't feel
like you're trying to listen it doesn't
surprise me that it's coming from this I
I've had this numerous times and fair
enough that yeah I I know I can I can
talk loud and I can be outspoken but I
know full world that what I'm saying is
not is true to me but you don't need you
don't know me at all that this is what I
was saying I weren't ever looking at you
when I said to you earlier about that
predator and what not that I've got
respect for men I have however just in
terms of like the world view and that
when we talk about oh they built this
world we should be we should be thankful
I I don't look at that I don't think
it's a nice place yeah because you don't
have a respect for men let's
um let's read the super chats and then
this wrap up okay
um okay guys
um thank you so much for the super chats
all of these go towards getting an 8K
camera and we really really appreciate
all the super chats while you're at it
make sure you like the video the like is
the number one metric that YouTube uses
to push out these videos um I'm only
going to be reading ones that are 10 or
more so if you have something that you
want to say make sure you you do it at
10 or more because we just don't have
time to read the five dollar ones okay
um Tim nurath I'm surprised you got a
man inside of you
um this woman is not listening not being
polite let me be a woman for a day and
tell her to believe me in X situation
um what horse Fess is
um ladies in the chat this is what all
men need to worry this is why all men
need to worry about every single
interaction we might have with a woman
woman we never know when we might run
into this mgtow by Logic we went an hour
without talking about the woman's
problem how dare we talk about men's
problems and then talk about female
great victims in order to make women the
focus of everything again
um gagu truth um this woman is actually
doing men a favor by not getting married
she is straight up evil and the guy
who's sitting close to her in the Lakers
please just be careful when you talk so
you don't touch her
um Samantha as a woman who used to live
in the ghetto areas in the U.S New
Jersey I was never scared but I was
always cautious and I was always home at
night because I didn't like to be
outside gallon um Sisterhood of the
Traveling Vic victimhood Pete Pearl
she's right about the UK though the
Rodan ham gangs and others got away with
charges for a decade because of the woke
police policies
certac Pearl both Utah YouTube and Tick
Tock have how to destroy a man channels
they're both monetized
um James Sharp I used to work in law
enforcement any woman who's actually
graped and she chooses not to report it
that's her fault also her silence is
automatically protecting The Grapist
that's the reality Gallant Prime
Humanity should mandate a reading of To
Kill a Mockingbird simply due to people
and narratives like this any man can be
a Tom and have their life burdened to
Cinders vanity Rose the only guy she
needs to worry about bumping into a dark
alley
the only guy she needs to worry about
bumping into a dark alley went wears the
top hat cape and carries a Gladstone
doctor's bag see sertac the authorities
need to take her son away right now from
this missandris this is sickening Sean
no lying about grape in order to put a
man in prison or ruin his life is just
as bad as grape I've literally had a
couple friends who almost had their
lives ruined because of a toxic woman
like this see sir that the level of
indoctrination that this level of
indoctrination is cancer in the world
each of these NPCs gets a vote which is
the whole point the government controls
women's Minds by scaring them
just pearly things are starting to get
the audience captured now that she is
missing many good points for team woman
not men is an insult meant as caption
caution plus the lady in the Hat is
attractive simp
finding this convo to be reminiscent to
the Russia Ukraine situation Ukraine was
attacked and approached and approached
Russia to establish a piece following
Russia disrespected Ukraine multiple
times and Ukraine walked Walked Away men
operate the same way Laker jersey guy is
not being feminine
because he communicates with the
significant other communication is
essential for a healthy relationship red
pill men tend to overcompensate to
appear masculine the men oh I read that
one
um chill and versatile checking is an
arguing checking is telling a woman what
it is and if she doesn't like it then
you all move on if a woman tells her man
to shut up and he puts his head down and
says nothing it looks weak AF Lakers on
um Maurice Alex you're shaming the dude
do you don't think that is feminine sign
language a man calmly will calmly
diffuse while making it known to his
girl that he what she said is not cool a
boy will give the silent treatment this
helps no one to La Jersey the masculine
thing to do is to lead by sitting there
and telling her prehand what to do is
feminine show your boundaries not tell
her simple bro NSX Pearl Sarah Lakers
got this right watch it back you've
blown his original point out of
proportion and taken it onto a wild
tangent which is not where he started at
Lakers is not the feminine one most guys
set their boundaries when we are dating
before we get into a relationship status
go down to
repeal a cage Jack repeal the 19th
Amendment it was the worst addition to
the Constitution because it gave women
undue and undeserved power voting came
with responsibilities but these Street
Walkers lack those Maurice Pearl telling
a woman not to talk to you disrespectful
is not feminine it's called having a
standard but going back and forth with
her in an argument is feminine I agree
with what the Lakers guy is saying
um 90 Frito pie I'm the hamburger
McDonald's isn't scared of being
attacked she's afraid that she won't
help afterwards Pearl pie likes apple
pie all the places she named her and
mostly non-white areas ironic Matt
butcher this is a great show showing how
irrational resentment can be manifested
into a life view then suppress or
Justify anger and project it onto the
other gender I hope the lady on the
couch gets help the lady in the striped
shirt instead of looking at the men
beside you as threats look at them as
protectors take thank them instead of
blaming and blaming and you'll feel safe
the rest of your life I'm FS Claire
this is modern Marxism and Kennedy's
argument current discrimination is the
answer for past discrimination this is
what you're seeing on the couch now NSX
some Sydney nightclubs really made it an
offense to dance stare or Advance
without consent women just tell a
bouncer guy that he stared or danced
without consent and they are kicked out
the popo is called our pain finally
thank you JPL you are the first woman
ever mentioning missandry the UK
Economist um why is your guests going
after losers why doesn't she find a good
decent man instead
um
uh 20 why so serious a woman's fear has
been monetized by the media and feminism
telling her to fear everything a man
does in including existing that's all of
them
okay and then I'm guys if you put any
super chats while we're doing final
thoughts I'll read them at the end
before we close final thoughts
um on this show Miss Andrei versus
misogyny um we'll go around from here
and we'll go this way
that's interesting
um
very insightful
um
I don't have anything else to say I
think I'm still taking it downloading
yeah
oh me yeah um
I suggested to myself I think it's a
consequence of misogyny I think um if
you sort that out then maybe people
wouldn't hate men so much
um our society
is we've normalized missandry and it's
essentially built into the core of
feminism the idea of patriarchy who do
bad things just because they're meant
not because of any other factors
geopolitical political environmental
it's just because they're men and that's
that's the the core issue
um I would implore you guys to respect
your boundaries
um and to show your boundaries rather
than negotiate your boundaries with you
know the world and people around you and
I think that's that's a masculine way to
live life but I understand everyone's
got their own approach
um and you can catch me at santochuku
um I do coaching now so
if if you need kind of the context to to
these ideas and the breakdown of exactly
why why I think this is the best
approach behaviorally I'm definitely
going to hear you hit me up I'm going to
experiment with your approach I
definitely want to put it we'll talk bro
because I actually think you remind me a
lot of me in terms of like you're
feminized without knowing it by society
and the way people treat you right I I
like you you're a good looking guy all
right you're well spoken but the the way
you're saying certain things are you run
my I mean you you you know okay me being
who I am doesn't make me feminine you
know so but yeah I like your [ __ ] man
I'll try it out listen we all got
feminine things I can talk fast how
about how about I'm just I'm I'm just
different kind of man I'm a new age man
I'm I'm me for me modern gotcha gotcha
yeah cool go on your final thoughts
um I just think this is all is all a lot
like
I'm still processing it I think I've got
a headache
I don't blame you
all right
um my final thought is
if you have watched
two or more of our videos and you have
not subscribed
then we have what Pearl beef what do we
have beef exactly so we better do that
now over to you bro okay I'm gonna read
the last couple of super chats because I
know you guys are putting a couple to
read before the show ends
um okay Robbie dude in the white is beta
AF using feminine tactics because he is
intimidated by Lakers guy are those
white capris come on
um just human is your guest aware of the
Salem witch trials and the society at
this time people were believed to
practice witchcraft based on accusation
does she believe those women were
treated fairly Tim nurath um these men
are trying to move away from her
um ciscoos it LLC certainly today we
have more sensitivity awareness and
woman Victim Advocacy groups programs
acts Etc to promote reporting and
protecting women grape or abuse victims
and yet the numbers declined copper
philosophy
um question question is what she defines
as grape if I message a girl to do our
thing and then two days later she wants
a relationship but I don't is that grape
um okay that's that's all of them let me
just refresh real quick guys a couple
announcements before we end the show so
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell make sure
you like the video on your way out also
guys um sign up for a membership tier if
you want to be a part of the chat next
time
um on top of that we have Vlogs in our
Discord at the second tier I'm getting
pretty good at Discord so you guys
should sign up for that third tier you
get to connect with us on social media
and fourth tier you get a one-on-one
consultation with me once a month
um there's two more Super chats that
just came through to keep our
animalistic nature at Bay as much as
possible it's better to have certain
Norms such as believe women when it is
the issue of grape don't be grandmothers
or don't pee outside
um Edgar guy on the white sounded
manipulative okay that's the last one
I'm done reading them
um
also guys make sure you subscribe to our
two clips channels um we have just
pearly clips and pearl daily thank you
for 430k that's a really big yeah yeah
we have you
you actually baffled me with how quick
we've grown the last six months like I
think I was at 20 000 subscribers six
seven months ago so this [ __ ] is mad uh
make sure you go follow my Instagram
just dot pearly things type out the
whole thing because I am Shadow band
follow my two Tick Tock accounts just
dot or just pearlythings.4 and dot five
um we're gonna have a Members Only Live
soon while we're me Jess and blessing
have some pizza after the show you can
ask us some behind the scenes questions
like you know favorite guests whatever
um also DM Eddie if you want to come on
the show don't forget to subscribe and
we will talk to you next time peace